how many international masters does it
take to host a blitz deathmatch show the
world is about to find out right here
with me are the the one and only two one
and only x' international master
lawrence trent an international master
John Bartholomew who've been throwing
down all week on Twitter now we're gonna
throw down on the board gentlemen are
you ready ready as I'll ever be
I second that I am totally ready to
throw down Annie
all right well to remind all the fans of
what's at stake here there is already
two thousand dollars in prizes via chess
calm it is fifteen hundred on the line
for the players themselves that's a
thousand to the winner and five hundred
to the loser and then an additional $500
courtesy of just calm going to the
winners charity of choice but apparently
that wasn't enough for these two maybe
there are adrenaline junkies I don't
know what you guys are about but they
they've been wagering all week on
Twitter that apparently you both have an
additional $500 on the line to go to the
charity what's going on with that tell
the fans yeah so he Lawrence he called
me out where he tried to call me out he
wanted a side wager of the winners purse
so he said let's surround $1,000 each
and see who takes this thing but I
responded that it might be better to do
it for charity so I responded let's do a
charitable bet so okay the winner of
this match gets to determine where the
money goes
$500 to charity so it'll be $1,000 total
being donated which i think is great
Lawrence wasn't into the whole charity
thing or he was he were you buddy
well look I mean you know Jon's been
very very generous in offering to pay an
extra five hundred right you know I'm
just glad he accepted the offer
he kind of begrudgingly accepted I mean
he made a bet with Greg Shahaji as well
I think he was very excited about that
side action I mean all things guys is
that you know this is this is gonna be a
fun stream it's gonna be it's gonna be
colorful but it is for a good cause so
anybody out there as what and already
speaking of those watching we already
had the the one and only chess Bay
the the chess queen goddess herself I
don't even know what to refer to chess
pay as these days she's probably
twitches biggest chess philanthropist
but chess bay coming in with $200 before
the match is even started and that's
even before Lawrence has said I'll check
me John and 15 moves if someone can
donate a thousand so okay we'll see what
happens before the day is over but what
I want to say is knowing Lawrence chant
Trent probably he's figured out a way to
make money on this John whether he wins
or loses so I don't know what's actually
with the side action
I was speculating that he might be the
first one in Deathmatch history to
actually lose money because of a death
match right because of the Oman he's
been alive so well either way there's uh
there's gonna be a lot of fun today
everybody if you're just tuning in we
will be on the homepage of twitch we
expect a lot of fans to be jumping in
and saying what in the world is this
reminder to all the fans and parents of
fans this is a parental advisory show
these two have been told to keep it
relatively clean but during these new
mutual trash talking death matches that
we're doing started with Simon Williams
have been Feingold now here we intend to
let the players go at it and and let
them let their thoughts be be known and
Lawrence has some things to say before
the stream about John in regards to
whether he could stay on his level with
trash talk I'm just gonna say that now
so we'll see I mean look at that we've
got a name but I can't say it says the
Danny looks paler than space yeah
there's something going on with our
camera as far as the exposure I agree
with you um I don't know what's going on
with that but I'm not gonna be on camera
for the most of the day this is not
about me I'm gonna be in the background
but one thing you will see that's gonna
be pretty cool I'm gonna show you right
now is we will have a view that provides
analysis of the players while they're
playing so these two will be going at it
on the big board on the Left I will be
analyzing giving different ideas no
engine eval bar just me trying to say
what I think is going on on the board
over there so for those of you watching
the stream there'll be some extra
edumacation while they blunder and screw
things up over there on the big board so
anyway are you guys are you guys ready
you ready throw the rock I'm pumped yeah
I can't wait so two hundred dollars and
one cent tonita donated just now by
Tommy so he just outdid chess babe I
by one says so it's it's getting nuts
you guys are already playing for more
than you thought you'd be it's chess
it's trash talk everybody it's time Pete
that's my guy that's my secret guy
behind the curtains let's do this thing
let the games begin and I'm gonna take a
back seat right now I'm eating this pea
Tommy Shelby I'm here I'm just gonna
sort of breathe in a bit before I make
my first move I'm gonna say cheers to
everybody out everybody watch in
supporting chess calm remember a lot of
money's gone to charity just they just
donated 250 unbelievable before I've
even made my first move cheers guys
cheers ready go I'm late for I can I
also wanted to say thank you to Jess
comm for putting this on really great to
be a part of this and thank you to those
who have already donated and who are
already tuning in it's already getting
it's already getting bananas so I don't
even know what to say about and that's
the nicest we should be all stream right
I think we may have to turn off the
jingle honestly but we can't do that we
can't silence the the donations so here
we go here we go you know I was
expecting Finn's you know you know he's
gonna be playing as classical stuff I'm
trying Harry
game one buddy you see my area of the
board this look look look oh my god
you're toast you are absolutely toast I
got to put a stop to Harry before he
gets too far down the boards you are
absolutely toast what friends doesn't
realize is I am the world's leading
expert in this particular variation mmm
that's what he doesn't get this was that
part of my career match preparation I
got to say no I can I can guess it was I
can guess now I know I have to play this
move I know it looks crazy I know that
it looks funky but I know I gotta play
it okay because believe it or not this
is what we call a bitter home peanut
butter rossion you walk straight into it
as I expected absolutely
okay note Donny's home look it's still
early
the laughs over here I'm sorry oh by the
way the donations already up to $2,600 I
just want to thank everybody who donated
while we were getting the show started
that I didn't get a chance to shout out
I will be doing that that's my only role
here is to thank all of you for
supporting these two jokers mm-hmm
by the way you know I just want to let
everybody go no that's um I had somebody
very special flying and helped me out in
this event and he is in here with the
room with me he's helping me prep up
which is really amazing of him and I
want you guys to to really say big thank
you here to mr. Allen Hambleton who's
flown in all the way from Canada I know
you're sort of on stream before this guy
he's got a smiley face he's got his
Harold's yeah he did his hair up yeah
good yeah mine and you can see he's got
a little badge there that says GM he
likes to wear that now so thank someone
for hanging out with me buddy I know
you're smiling I appreciate all the work
you did for me okay what we got going on
so basically fins let's just get this
straight you're a piece down in Game one
our tempers when I've played the move b3
and h4 I had to spy you some sort of
odds Lawrence I mean we got to make the
second fight there buddy that is an
achievement that is an achievement I
promise you what are you gonna do here
buddy let's roll let's soar Derek up the
board okay all right just rolling it
down okay
so I've seen that I think I'll pass
thanks I think I'm past that one but I
do appreciate it I appreciate your
donations guys by the way whoa what's
this
Oh Derek I mean for goodness sake it's
unbelievable he might land on cetera -
hey Mike did you learn it-- I think
there's a good chance of him landing
there mm-hmm
so what we gonna do about that probably
not much right probably not much sir
probably got a ticket I think probably
gonna take it yeah
don't want to take it I just want to say
thank you to everyone in the twitch chat
for their support I don't see fire
emojis right now but I know I'm going to
see them soon gonna have to take it feel
pretty sick about that I would feel sick
too I'm a pretty sick feel pretty sick
we got a race in icy position already
don't we more is it that messy just
looks winning for you just looks good
for you buddy
well you said this is home prep I gotta
give you the benefit of the doubt
yeah you probably taking on before was
not my finest move in history okay so
you can't believe your opponent right
isn't that a number one rule of Poker as
well probably probably okay whatever so
the question is we know we're lost here
that's that's that's not a problem the
question is how lost are we you know yes
I probably shouldn't have taken that
night in fairness probably I should have
played something else you know in
hindsight hindsight it's a wonderful
thing it's always 20/20 right it's
always 20 timing
I've still got swindling opportunities
here though you know yeah I do see some
interesting ideas for you I've got some
swindling opportunities here I ain't
givin up I ain't givin up your Queens
running out squares there John
I'm not worried yet let's Parker on d4
for now you Parker wherever you want my
friend you Parker wherever you want ah
that what I was not expecting that was a
bit out of what we call net field where
I'm from yeah I mean we would say the
same but is it a good move no but that's
Pacific to the point
okay so d5 you can play 96 it's maybe
your plan
good big what if I actually I don't know
if I actually mind that Lawrence hmm you
mind not minded maybe I won't blame 86
yeah let's see what you got actually
yeah kind of unfortunate
kind of unfortunate you sound like
Acharya very unfortunate it was very
unfortunate it's several unfortunate
frankly speaking frankly speaking it's
very unfortunate well so you forgot the
nevertheless Tian but when I did it but
I did award the five points for the very
quick Franklin say you know I'm keeping
score someone has already accused us in
the chat of this banter being forced
which I gotta say it's this is coming
from the heart yeah I am kind of curious
about something that I'm curious about a
little something going on
so sad I'm curious about your time
situation yeah me too brave before II
and thanks for the hundred bucks dude
you're awesome
not looking good what time situation has
to be so sad I'm serious about your time
situation inevitably I'm the one who's
in time pressure whenever I strain but
this is a bit different of a format so
it's just going a bit too pear-shaped
for my liking you know I I guess I guess
we're just gonna do it he's gonna go for
it
mm-hmm king daeso yeah so what is the
big deal so Wesley that looks like a
rock it is a rope
well done what do you want to metal that
pony is looking a bit lonely on a a - it
is looking lonely it is looking lonely
I'll be honest with you see where I
consider resigning this position yeah
okay John you know it's always bad luck
to to win the first one right it's
always always to win the first one I
tried to give you that head start but
yeah in winter she when you said take my
night you bluffed me huh he quickly went
pear-shaped God your face was in the
corner as well for when I was you know
when I was doing that so that that was
not fun here we go yawns build Tennessee
is that what you want no no I'm from the
northern part of the US here we go
mm-hmm you don't have to get my stress
ball though already sure that's not a
good sign
I know so is this how are you gonna play
against me so it's kind of weird you
know these kind of nonsense variations
with it's just what you're gonna do
against me I just got to stick to my
game plan which is as I explained in
that article just to get you out of your
comfort zone make you become hard on
yourself and defeat yourself ultimately
it's just some say luck is the residue
of design I don't know if you agree with
that I don't agree with that anything
you say I disagree with just
principle on principle exactly now I
guess I guess that's a standard kind of
move okay yep looks looks like sort of
move dakara would play in this position
I just think that you know you're just
not cut out for this chess business
drink I mean I've been told that before
you can have it you can have the f5 have
your buddy have all yours
try to stabilize you stabilize buddy you
do what you got to do yeah
got a block out that dark square Bishop
on g7 yeah you can try you can
definitely try okay let's swap a few
pawns off I know you you like that kind
of stuff I'm excited when you start
talking about trades I get a little bit
excited
I understand I've seen your games I
understand why trading makes you excited
yeah but like the Bernie Sanders of the
chess world you know it's an interview
comparison you're a good guy but my god
you wouldn't want in a dinner that's
tell you that you would just goodness me
so Lawrence um yeah are you gonna do
about this oh wow I didn't expect that
actually do you know what I just think
he missed a key I just completely missed
that you were lining that up if I'm
totally honest so I don't know quite
what I'm gonna do about it just yet but
first actually you're picturing Bernie
Sanders was surprised first thing I'm
gonna do is panic okay the second thing
is now I'm gonna do is that a bit
radical but you know we're hanging in
there when we're nowhere near lost we
are nowhere near lost this is a fun one
this gonna be fun this yeah this if this
backfires on you I promise it will be
really difficult for you to recover them
hahaha
I agree mentally this may be a problem
if I don't win this game
all right great be careful though
whatever you do remember to be careful
here you don't have to go all in here
you know okay yeah I can still keep it
relatively controlled I mean you can I
mean just you know just don't do
anything silly all right
don't do anything you would do don't do
anything silly yeah you know I like to
look at this so I'm gonna drop that in
unleash it I'm missing everything okay
you drop that in there looks like looks
like a good attendance I'll give you
that
holy cow
okay we'll retreat like a Frenchman's
yeah as Ben would say so now do I really
go all in
yeah you can do what you want because
that's always the decision right like I
bet the flop I bet the turn do I push
the ribeye roll me out anybody three
barrel you're the poker expert so
normally I would defer to you on these
matters but you're my opponents so
pretty barrel really you will shock me
no oh that's uh I think that's a reason
to do it yeah I did say that actually
got a sense of weakness I was bluffing
you now the good news is what is the
good news is there any good news good
news is you're not made it yet not yet
it's true I'm only down one pawn so
question is how would like que Cara hold
on here you play like this move right ah
doesn't that drop a piece Lourdes I
might be too liquored up to see it but
ya know I was just kidding
okay hmm
stabilization move maybe that was my
plan all along
you know lure you in room are you in and
punish you just punish you just punish
I'm gonna punish just me just venus
flytraps style look at that look at
these happy faces let's do this what
miss that I'll be honest I think I have
to say I didn't bring props so I feel a
bit left out already
you're pretty good now feel pretty good
about these you know unless I've missed
everything but you know Knights a good
defender strong that's what you've got
to learn Knights are good defensive
pieces now it's a really really really
good defense you know our unique strange
downing I play for the initiative baby
what's that initiative I do have one
pawn for it but the initiative is more
important not true now I have to
actually play some good moves right
so what are you actually friending are
you actually threatening anything decent
my my guests do you know what my guess
is is no hmm my guess is that this is
just
better than nothing as Trump would say a
nothing but a nothing burger yes this is
a nothing but what do you actually want
to do tell me tell me what you want your
plan is here okay you want to do that
cuz you're sick and then you want to do
that because you're sick of you have got
quite a bit of initiative yeah I'll give
you that don't know what to do here hmm
you know just it's just a tricky kind of
position it is it's a bit tricky it's
really tricky okay some potentially fun
stuff for both sides right this sums
there's stuff going on here that's for
sure there's a lot of stuff you know
what's his art hmm
let's start with a check Alina lush
Lamba and another check Alina yeah is
that you trying to see if I'm still
paying attention yes I was just making
sure there Dan there was a test that I
passed okay see you so I gotta hear your
voice chuckling what do you that's the
kind of thing that people get ridiculed
for John and my book you know you're
you're too straight arrow for that don't
make up your own words what are you
gonna do Wow Ricky one is not a threat
come on damn it
sometimes John's chess is just it's too
smooth right Lawrence to so sick okay I
don't mind giving back all the material
all of them well if I get my King safe
I'll flag you you know that's the that's
the bottom line I think I'm getting my
king safe in my god boy I do like
because yeah that that should ensure I I
shouldn't lose on the flag at least in a
non complicated position
yeah hey
you
okay
no need to rush
didn't see down on john-boy that I
didn't see though hmm
now we got a bit of an interesting
little what I like to call endgame you
like to call it an endgame I do you're
gonna watch these out watch out for
these pawns you know I'll try okay first
we'll double always a good thing
like my first ever chess teacher said
double on the default if anything else
double on the deef oh that's not advice
I think now let's just adjust mine now
so I don't mass slip because that really
would hurt very much we can change a
pair of rooks here just because you know
that's that's what we gots to do you're
using my strategy you want to swap on
I'm gonna swap here okay I should have
pre moved that okay so now we're gonna
start chasing some pawns
well win one how about we win want just
to like start off yeah let's just get
things started
yeah then we're gonna win the other then
we're gonna win them all all right we're
going to take everyone and then we get a
queen we're not even gonna Queen are
thorns we're gonna make them all nice
I'm gonna make you all right
shout out to everybody donating $1
thousand dollars everything is awesome
you guys are so great for supporting the
show not sure that Laurence's banter
deserves it but either way we appreciate
appreciate the look my pants is top
class
give me that that's a that's a class
move there John that is a classy move
from a classy koenig I'll give you that
well I've been making a meal of this
game as you guys would say yeah you have
been making a meal
you've been making a big old meal hmm
and I'm eating it all up baby all comes
alright I'll just have to try to track
down these pawns yeah you track them
down you track them down maybe meet you
with Bishop and I versus Cape it's
always possible all right
okay mm-hmm
this one will tell me let's have you
don't win yeah
you
this one will tilt me I gotta keep
pushing forward even though I don't like
it look I'm gonna start pushing some
pawns you know a wise man once told me
push the balance lose this game is what
he said yes okay is this where we bungle
this nah surely not
no no well yeah I can't even lose this
one come on that we got this I do think
I got this one well I'm really annoyed
with how it's all gone
you
rook TV was nice I gotta hand it to you
guys a nice resource we got my Starbucks
though I'm in it for the long haul
alright just if you're gonna do it just
do it don't mess around and just do it
just do it now I really want to go there
but I know something six gonna happen
then I'll feel sick or late surely I've
got too much space here no I understood
you were going to do that then I thought
I would do this I have to try something
I thought I'd do this and then I thought
I would just wing it you know but I mean
what's your threat here is that a threat
I'm also about to flag so you've got
that going for you
holy smokes what have I done to this
position what have I done to this
position it's a bit sick right okay
whatever it is really really do I even
start thinking about winning chances
that would be too much winning chances
would be too much what the hell have I
done I'm going on definitely
what the hell did I just maintain the
fortress I mean for real did this really
just happened and this really just
happened I mean this really just happens
to me Lawrence I will give you a mercy
draw in this position I know you just
lost all your pawns so I feel a bit bad
proposing it not having you proposed it
John you're preventing the site there's
a whole side action going and twitch
about whether you'll come back and made
him with the knight bishop you didn't
you didn't allow it all right we eight
hundred and twenty seven dollars eight
hundred twenty seven dollars and twenty
minutes for you guys
Wow thank you guys so much it's amazing
the twitch support this is what this is
why the twitch community is the Jewish
community honestly it's it's just it's
amazing so that's just phenomenal thank
you to everybody for your support
Lawrence it's time to rematch buddy not
the bottle but the mouse there you go
yeah can you send that again sorry oh I
was so excited I clicked out of it
classy classy move I'll send you on it
child apparently can somebody set that
up for us cuz I just tried small start
your game thanks Danny you guys are
there we go here we go thanks daddy
Danny you can try this Sicilian stuff
again I don't mind right it's the third
it's the third game slow very weak
because I wanted you to know Lawrence
someone on Twitter not just someone the
Anton Squared me aka Dan he gave a
fantastic suggestion he said I should
give you a copy of my chesil repertoire
on the Scandinavian right as a prize for
this match I mean Carlos can I actually
could I actually get a copy of that of
course yeah Danny I'll hook you up Wow
how is it that I'm already out of look
here do we retreat like a Frenchman
you're nothing did someone do his
homework or not I wasn't expecting the
Queen da Karen a scandi I should say so
no yes yeah clearly you didn't check out
my repertoire Lawrence Oh
this is what you suggested yes yes yeah
now we know why there's a draw problem
in chess you know people like you
kidding all the fault of the
Scandinavian god I'm already just
struggling here it's too sick for words
too sick for words dudes
I guess we're already worse right is
that what it says in your book then
we're worse here already right am i
repertoire to but I have my worthless
still at that assumption
I guess I'm worse here right that's the
that would be the sensible thing to to
say I guess I'm just worse but you're
getting a resourceful guy I mean based
on that yeah I mean I really was not
expecting that to be honest no I know
you're gonna get in trouble at some
point you know basically you know
um so I guess resourcefulness can go
both ways right like you can play good
moves and you can just botch completely
winning positions oh yeah as you just
saw I'm very capable I'm the master of
the botch I always think when I'm in a
position what would what would Magnus do
you know and I never come up with the
right answer that's that's kind of the
issue we're gonna we're gonna we're
going to do something that's just
probably terrible but we don't care
we're gonna outplay John mm-hmm
for Johnny and I know once there's a bit
of a poll going right now I just want to
clue you into it there's a bit the side
action that you're so famous for
enjoying is whether you will finish with
more glasses of wine than points so
they've been tracking it so far that's
yeah I mean maybe if maybe a draw here
would be a fair result I just need to
get a few points on the ball we got a
long time to go yeah it's a long match
long ambitions too early no needs a
panic at all gear guys no need
whatsoever Road c7 very much in a John
Parr Ptolemy's fashion I like it I like
it okay I think we're going to have to
just play
a bit more what I like to call just show
you us a contempt you know show you
utter contempt and just you just let the
hands fly let the hands fly as you say
let the hands fly absolutely
so what's going on in this position
Mullins a bit hard to see er it feels
like I should be okay
nothing more nothing less I want to see
if you'll go back with your tail between
your legs what is that you just want to
win a pool no I just want to see you
player okay one again I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna spite you yeah I'm gonna spite
you these positions are tricky is this
where I get outplayed I did have
something like this in title Tuesday
okay I want to play rook takes c3 so it
doesn't work I want to play it so bad do
it then five dollar donation there
thanks guys I do think it might be you
guys you could have a scrum to play with
sexy wow there's some sicko stuff here
Lawrence
are you seeing what I'm saying I tell
you what I'm having my wine I'm gonna
let you think about it and then when you
wash out and play some other move I'm
gonna wash out I play a different move
but it might be a good move
whew just dumb I want you to appreciate
to appreciate what I think I'm
appreciating here oh wow
totally smokes now I'll give you credit
cuz that weren't on my radar so I mean
once you see that move you gotta play it
right like that's morally for sting so I
think you do Wow
holy sickness holy sickness if that
works
I think it worked I think I'm dealing
with a genius guys it's a very stable
genius at that a very stable genius as
well Wow
how bad do I run how bad do I
I'm gonna run all the way to that side
well I mean what am I gonna do get John
I mean you're you're lost I mean for
crying out loud you're just a monster
I tried flashes of Justin you're just a
monster buddy what can I say
I mean this is just so gross I have no
words for it just the most gross thing I
think I've ever seen okay yeah I think
like seriously what the hell is this
what kind of a move is 95 I mean for
real there's quite a fun one to play
God's sake
it's just not even sure you should be
you should be punished I'm gonna punish
you okay you still wanted to go Rio I
really wanted to play route takes III
but that just meant the stands I
understand what you want to do you know
you're a sick man what can I say you're
just a sick human being I underestimated
your sickness let's try to make a draw
so that everyone looks pretty badly out
of the game you want to draw
oh no absolutely not why not not yet at
least
come on okay well that was the one I was
hoping for actually if I'm so it be
honest mm-hmm that wasn't sure I mean
your rook looked a little weird over
there but I was that was the one of all
the moves I was hoping for that was the
one hmm have to say have to say have to
be honest have to be honest with you
cheers guys may you all have a healthy
life play a lot of chess how about y'all
follow me on Twitter how about that for
start for a good New Year's resolution
others are you sure they want to follow
you if your unverified after this match
that's true okay in d6 was a good move I
think I'm gonna get the King involved in
the endgame right dude you really do
it's so important people just don't
appreciate it you know you got to keep
your King out yeah that's a good move as
well can you stop playing good moves
please let me have a bit
this position is just so utterly gross
it's probably drawable for you right I
think so what I've missed is like a key
concept in the whole line anyway cuz I
can just do that
he had I had I actually calculated that
Oh actually I could only do it on that
move that's right
hey I'm gonna make a draw if I'm lucky
I'm so happy I'm not following the chat
I can just imagine what these glasses
you can just learn know what the final
results were of the poll yes definitely
over/under glasses of wine set around 72
over/under points right now at about
four so honestly I think that was pretty
good Lauren so I know 772 glass of wine
four points that's okay they're just
rollin you buddy you're doing good you
know what I'm just I want to be the
positive voice of you're not that bad
today okay yeah that's a good that's a
good stop I misunderstood 72 people
think it'll be more wine for people
think it'll be more points I don't know
that's better or worse but I needed to
clarify if it's in if it's more wine
than points we've got a serious issue
but also as I read 72 glasses of wine I
was like really even for Lawrence that's
a lot of wine and I you know I didn't
understand so that is quite a bit of
wine okay John you've you forced me to
do this let's see what you got let's see
what you get just forced me to do all of
this stuff and don't hate me for it if
you do not read all right promise you
won't hate me
you
he promised he won't age
just promise me let's
behind here you get behind you get
behind your pawns
you know that's a good start you're a
huge fish because you didn't analyze
anything but it's it's fine yeah such a
fish
such a fish it's hard to tell which is
better the knight of the bishop in this
position right one of a toss up kindly
really slow - this is the three minute
portion or five minute me yeah this is
the frogmen I'm taking my time as much
as I can't you know definitely that
surprised me that liver surprised me I'm
taking more time as much mm-hmm as much
as I as much as I possibly can
yeah that was really that is a double
attack that was really not clever at all
holy cow I'm just so awful oh my god why
do
do that why have I done this again I'm
just so hopeless
I'm just so unbelievably hopeless
Laurens self self-deprecation is for our
three buddy right now we're yeah that's
true yeah right now he's using to be
confident trash talk right yes we're
good here buddy we're making a draw no
sweat
look at those dolls great block it does
web blockades mm-hmm Petrosian would be
proud really the money show me the money
honey
Oh doesn't quite work that was a
miscalculation
my heart bleeds yeah but maybe you my
king can get in we'll see what happens
not yet though got to be careful gonna
be a big cap full here huh don't want to
go blundering that away yeah well so
it's this is really tricky when you know
it's really true it's just really really
really tough I'm really happy with I'll
be honest with you now yeah okay like
yeah okay
you
let's try to get something going over
there do it you deserve it you deserve
it but
this is tricky huh hmm okay
I'll be honest be yeah you really want
to go down here you're going to you
really want to go down this route push
it baby
just like yeah sir you really want to go
down what
you really wanted to do this you sure
about that Lawrence oh no ok you sure I
am sure about anything but I think
that's the so clams color bishop I
understand
so sick it's the so-called correct
corner yes
put the Bishop on b7 I hate my life
if it makes you feel any better Lawrence
it says painful for us as it is for you
right now he's gonna get an endgame
complex say this is your chance in yrs
to remember there's there's always the
possibility that you finish with more
glasses of wine than points I don't have
to drink so much wine but that's you
know that's neither here nor there how
long we got off this portion you got
plenty of time you got 49 minutes
remember you were also getting your ass
kicked by me before you came back on
each one am I playing with Magnus
Carlsen odds here what's going on oh
yeah
this is it you didn't notice Lawrence do
you recognize this position are you
having a lovely I'm gonna laugh with you
were trolling you did two and a half
points so we figured we might want to
remind you of what that mystery for you
oh my oh my r.i.p jokes over abort the
game give John we were waiting for you
guys to notice all right all right
thought it was a chest accomplished
honestly I was trying to resize my voice
it could be with chess calm there's a
million glitches so good oh yeah you're
you're sitting there like okay chess
comp bug strike again I'm down with rook
against noise we were hoping Lords with
head start having flashbacks and Magnus
would be like you know appearing in
front of him I just want everybody to
know a little something right a little
little something I got my revenge don't
you worry about that guys I got my
revenge in a big way oh yeah I guess
against Magnus do you want to share that
story well basically he had an event in
Hamburg very recently and you know it
was his play Magnus event his brand and
I hosted the event and after the event
it's very nice event he said come on
lens let's play some chess I said buddy
I'm not interested in playing the rook
down again so whatever let's just play
some normal gist he said okay we'll play
some time odds so I said all right we
could play some time odds buddy and I
crushed him so you know some of the
games are going to be
the video is now kind of ready so you
guys just watch out for that and you're
gonna see me doing in the world champion
the fact that I can't be Finn's yes
that's not a good recommendation for you
for that video yeah I've just realized
as well that I'm just I'm gonna have to
cut cut down on the wine I think so
sorry that moment of truth I'm just
curious I didn't see that funny in the
world I'll be honest you are just a huge
fish and you're just an amazingly huge
fish I mean amazing at least I'm honest
with you right
I mean hey it is all about honesty chef
comes bugs Lawrence's letting it all
hang out with the wine and and Johnny's
uh I mean real friends here I wouldn't
lie to you guys
you're just a huge huge fish on ok so I
know what you're trying to do Johnny and
it ain't gonna work
ok just ain't gonna work my user name is
Finn so the fish part is not that
offensive that's true yeah where does
that come from by the way Finn's
I'm sure if you have a youtube video on
it but I might know that's ok it's a
it's a Jimmy Buffett song so Jimmy
Buffett songs Finn's I was listening to
it when I made that username it's not
not a very good story about the Sam
Copeland who just subscribed with twitch
Prime Oh baby the twitch Prime in the
house yes mate just BAE gifting
memberships to Anton squared me Dan the
one and only my Twitter gif himself he
definitely deserves it
Anton Square me deserves a lot of stuff
he works hard he's the funniest dude we
gave him a diamond membership we want it
we want we always want to do stuff with
Dan yeah he's awesome he does great work
dan is just what we call a legend where
I'm from they take Eric Davis one two
three four four the sub all right I'm
gonna have to start playing some proper
chess soon guys just let me know how I'm
supposed to play this position should we
let you know when we're ready for you to
start playing proper chess yeah I play
some proper John are you ready yet not
sure
I've been ready okay he was born ready
okay I'm out of ideas so I'm just gonna
do that hmm have I blundered something
else no no okay
just gonna go here because I like seeing
you go back to the original swear
posture if I get another oh yeah I'm
over the moon yes thank you our star for
the sub there buddy this is a sort of
position you just made your career you
know I think that's that's the sad thing
you've just made your bones on this you
have been studying my games I have your
you are a darn fine player sir if I may
salsa Thank you Thank You Lourdes a darn
fine player never have I ever seen
somebody quite like you I have to say I
do love these small stable advantages
you do and you deserve them no risk just
no risk involved Thank You Jess pay for
the last gift to heart are missed it
I'm not blundering what you'll think I'm
just letting you know Lawrence how many
genome norms do you have by the way I've
got to but I've got he's got like 17 but
I'm gonna make a weird glitch in the
system it got lost in payroll and the
mail department and that kind of thing
that old story how about you I don't
actually know ah
not as many as that I only have one
unfortunately so some would say you'll
hop off the GM I am yeah
that's pretty much when it comes down to
if I put it in an exceptional
performance maybe feed able rate this
event I hope so
I might have the performance rating with
two and a half out of three already
shout out to proj one when who just
subscribed with twitch prime why is it
JL chess was just gifted a sub by the
one and only chess BAE why is my
position so bad
chess Bay's putting in work Thank You
chess babe she's she started the party
with a 200 other donation before the
game started
set the tone for chess mm-hm yep all
right let's play a little tickle there's
a knee hey you know how I feel about
tickle mmm that is a tickle and off I
realized this year John that so many
lies I might have to cut down on the
whining certain folks so many videos we
made it at the camp this year we're not
PG enough to make it online next year we
got to clean it up to get a little more
of that that is yeah that's - people are
talking about just how how how clean you
are I am - in general I mean I I enjoy a
subtle reference or some sort of sexual
joke I can pull over on someone from
time to time we know that I can do that
but the most part ever think I'm pretty
clean but John you're the poster child
for quality Ches entertainment mmm yeah
you you see you uh you walk a fine line
Danny a nice line you know and I try I
try to walk that line okay this has got
to be like an auto queen sack it's not
even a queen sack we're getting subs
everywhere t CMIT
TS 70 Christopher Christoph's Z s I
think I think I missed another gift by
Ches Bay thank you to everybody for your
love and support let's remember let's
get those donations to 3,000 before we
hit the 3-minute mark let's let's get
160 bucks in donations for John I mean
Lawrence I I didn't want to talk about
why you're always losing once I thought
we're gonna talk about that maybe a
three is the best move up played old
match with desperate man right there
desperate times maybe a three is just
the best move I played in to see such
psyche sicko stuff here really really
gonna cut down on the wine just such
sicko stuff alright for the crowd you
did it
you did it Congrats holy smokes
this is gonna be more embarrassing loss
a little time
the Eagles gonna land Bishop h6 yeah Wow
like this is like I keep trying to
imagine a variation where you don't have
to Queens on the board yet get Jeff
mated Lawrence but I can't think of it
before the analysis board so that the
fans can see what's coming this is so
unbelievably good John will you take
Lawrence to Gap kids after you adopt him
that's a question that just no no no I'm
gonna get my kids like baby j.crew
something a little bit higher end
compared to gap okay there you go that's
spoken like a good daddy - although gap
is quite a good store I gotta say I've
never been a baby gap but Lawrence
deserves only the finest okay mate I'm
game really made it you know
really really made it it just makes me
so sad there's some savagery going on in
this chat I was just getting so made it
it's so gross
I might have to resign this one you know
I'm just a bit I'm a bit you know let's
all right this is the five minute
portion we'll have plenty of Allen
there's plenty of time that's right
it was tempting to try to find a
brilliancy there but probably not worth
it do it
find a brilliance think you deserve it
you are brilliant you're a brilliant guy
brilliant a brilliant man blondeness
you're a role model for the chess
community how long we got Danny flipping
back over to the scoreboard here we got
38 minutes left for the poster boy of
chess and the one backed up by Danny
here's to John Lorenson needs more wine
I couldn't finish the rest of that
statement the 38 minutes left buddy in
the five minute portion Lawrence how
much 38 minutes left let's see if I can
get a win on the board you know I think
we're gonna get to 3,000 in the next 30
minutes for you guys oh my got it
3,000 is would be amazing
that would be great I think we're in a
bit of Danny what I like to call issues
I think we have a few issues in this
position you know King has this running
shoes on I'll tell you that I mean do
you know what I've had enough yeah um
I'm sorry got to highlight why the
meeting that was coming before you
resigned Lawrence thank you for that
hey broke okay yeah did it that ain't
broke okay so this is your line 86 huh
the Queen D eights candy this is a six
is a carnist sweet moon okay you guys
know a little bit of history on this
line it was used by one Magnus Carlsen
in the Olympiad against one Fabiano kara
wanna really yes a 2014 now want to say
what you mean the one that I was
commentating on Oh was that I guess so
all right done I'll tell you what I'm
gonna do I'm what how many wines about
whatever the number they're gonna stop
right now
now I'm getting a bit I'm getting a bit
annoyed actually I'm getting a bit
annoyed the somebody of your quality and
I mean that in a very depreciate
play yeah just to clarify is holding out
on me in such a way that only me TV who
just subscribed I want to remind
everybody all of these donations go
directly to the players if you're just
joining the show nearly 3000 of you now
who are curious we've never done
donations on the show before because
we're here to to support you guys chest
comm it doesn't really look for
donations on its channel but in this
case it is going directly to the pockets
of John Bartholomew and Lawrence Trent
you're looking at those two beautiful
faces all that money goes to them yep so
keep the donations come in and we do
appreciate all the subs and support in
the channel as well three games is quite
a leap right that is sizable I would say
is it sizable ready
I mean there's a lot of games to be
played but how much time do we have left
in this portion we got a lot of games
yeah my games I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna freak out I'm gonna have to get
rid of this Scandinavian though that's
that's I know for sure this guy the
Navin is bugging me you got a call up a
man he's in the next room right like ask
him what do you should do I'm on buddy
what do I do against this Dan
Scandinavian you got your GM title yeah
okay so I'm only slightly was here right
that was a creative maneuver a five work
a four I mean it felt necessary somehow
do you remember why I felt necessary
remember why acts play but I did at the
time it must've shout out to rob set up
a username and just subscribe everybody
who said you guys are great sorry I'm
missing two shout out to everybody
trying to be quiet
okay um this position is disgusting
this position is utterly gross I'll be
honest with you hmm
okay I'm really gonna have to put my hat
on here you're thinking cap on let's do
this it's it's it's kind of its kind of
getting beyond reasonable now I would
say it's getting beyond reasonable I'm
gonna have to actually stop a bit of the
banks and play some chess here guys
because it's it's definitely not going
as I planned
it's definitely going worse than I
planned
let's just get a win on the board you
know just to make it make it you know
interesting you know what I mean that's
a good goof I mean you got some Bishop
takes f6 stuff to think about it's true
my Brookes covered I've got everything
covered at the moment it's not like you
know I'm dead lost right like you know
thinking right now by any means okay I
didn't want to retreat that night it was
great on b4 yeah I have to say okay now
what would Magnus play why is it I can
never answer that question see okay
we're just gonna we're gonna just play
like a worse here do you guys think
Magnus is watching right now they tend
to live my life like Magnus is always
watching yeah so right like he's always
around us Magnus is also because they
are literally watching me my office with
the Fatheads John I mean I literally
have them pointed at me all the time
that's sort of glaring support right
just in case
somehow I feel like my position is
improved I'll stream moves I have to say
something seems like it you're you're
proving that that rook a four might have
had some purpose exactly well Colin
Vandermeer just subscribed with a 999
sub Colin going big going big with the
999 sub thanks for the support so now I
can just retreat happily and it like
nobody knew the difference right yes
that's basically what's going on here
right Colin is a longtime viewer my
channel by the way so thanks for
watching Colin and subscribing okay hmm
it's a juicy Bishop have you see
see you later agent Jael chest looks
like you're bouncing appreciate your
support and honest thanks for the sub
you don't have what I don't want it
either I don't I mean it's juicy but
this also looks pretty nice oh wow
okay let's get Freddie involved you get
Freddie involved Freddie's my favorite
my favorite kind of guy okay
all right okay now what you're gonna do
I've just decided I've had enough of
your nonsense and I'm being no you're
getting far too complacent John you
might be out three then it will be two
then it'll be one then we'll be neck and
neck and you'll start being live so on
and so forth can never relax in these
matches that's one thing I've learned
this is now actually pretty gross for
you this is fun really
why would I panic it I mean this is a
gross really okay whatever I'm not
panicking in really okay don't panic
then see how I can again the times a
little bit of a concern but not gonna
panic on the board just sitting your
coffee okay what's the play here what to
play here against John this one's kind
of tricky huh
I'll play this you got to get that night
involved somehow
he's just Finnegan's I actually guessed
that move I'm basically playing guess
the move over here on the analysis board
but I guess fiendishly we probably do
that's not a good sign you don't ever
want to be in company with me I told you
that out of fair warning buddy
holy smokes
kappa blend would be rolling in his
grave yeah this is a controversial move
we'll see how it turns out really I mean
we got another like Bishop versus Knight
may be looking like it's headed towards
an endgame they worked out last time
yeah shout out to chess Bay who just
gifted a sub to the legendary fianchetto
welcome to the chat fianchetto Adam
Wallace Adam Wallace just don't need a
hundred dollars for team school and just
like that we're about to cross 3,000 I'm
on something about not on the Mon handed
in company with the spiked air who knew
he traveled so well holy cow that's
that's ridiculous
it's located right next to your bird
uncle bunk the the Chester is getting
way too positional for Lawrence's liking
this is getting way too sexy I'm really
I'm actually from hating this game I'm
really enjoying it you're really
starting to like it
yeah I'm not thrilled with my position
right now I gotta say to be honest this
is the happiest I've been in about an
hour
so yes pretty pretty pretty pretty
pleased with how things have kind of
happened here okay so much vegetable F
what was questionable that is sure okay
let's just not lose now you know
mm-hmm that would be really silly to
lose I know what you're gonna do is well
you're just so predictable
what is that dumbest move I've ever seen
I guess that wasn't what you were
expecting it does was a pawn but I
didn't see what you're up three pawns in
the other game so three connected
consoles I'll probably only make a draw
again if I'm lucky if you're lucky here
maybe I'll win the game that'd be nice
winning would be like super but I still
I'm pretty confident I won't deny I feel
pretty damn good I do feel good you know
okay
the night is too annoying okay well I'm
just gonna take the extra form and know
that I've got a draw even this one I
can't do this right mm-hm
would you agree with that that I would
agree with yeah losing this would be
impressive
yeah this would really take something
three three thousand dollars and more
than three thousand viewers we just did
a huge job not sure where that love came
from but we just jumped from about
averaging about 2900 viewers for the
last hour we're now at 3500 viewers
thanks everybody tell your friends I
think as the kids say G on the chat is
lit know what chat is lit okay so that
is lit I think that's a thing I don't
like this but I'm gonna go for something
moves either this or just struggle on
down upon and be passive yeah but I mean
you're gonna struggle down two pawns now
unless I'm unless I've completely missed
something which I don't think I have I
don't know I think chess Bay is
organizing a donate for Danny to get
lessons in accents with Meryl Streep
hears she's created a donation for me to
get trained I'm not sure if that's chess
pays
if she's supporting my accent usage or
if she's like begging me to get work on
it since I clearly refused to stop using
accents but I think John was there at
the birth of uncle Sasha uncle Sasha
after dark it came out yeah
uncle Sasha after dark yes yeah that was
this summer he when we first visited ooh
I'm such a poor end game player I just
I'm just utterly hopeless what are we
doing here like this I don't know I
guess I'm just gonna try and not lose
this position
I'm not sure what to do either I think
that was a good move do you think I was
messing I was at least trying to get my
king in but you stop that
okay now you're cops so at least I've
caught you now I am she forms up here
right I'm not hallucinating
yeah you're two thumbs up like I'm two
forms are the King's car that should be
Angwin I mean it really should be
really John really really now hmm are we
going down this road Johnny boy huh
another one let's give you another pod
and see what happiness John's made it
himself from time to time I'm pretty
pretty pen with the chest comrades
believe in your endgame technique fins
don't disappoint them this position is
probably not as bad as the second game
which I managed to safer a dress that's
exactly what you do you plant the seed
of doubt Lawrence's head that he's
already blown an easier position right
right
what the hell was gee fog checking
okay I'm just going to get some time on
the clock to try and actually convert
this if that's possible
do you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
play a sensible move Hey okay gonna play
something a tiny bit more sensible got
to do it right I mean I'll be honest
with you if this one I don't win I mean
it's the good news is you got the king
cut off and everything yeah I mean I
mean to not win this is is is pretty bad
that would be tragic would be tragic
I love having like additional time as
well that's really superb I've got the
king cut which is quite neat
do you know want to know something finns
that's really funny
yes i did this exact ending today with
one of my students really mm-hmm
the bridge huh just gonna do a bridge
buddy and he's gonna be watching as well
the technique that's really the for me
to clarify what you just said to the
world people pay you to go over and
games yeah sure
I'm just kidding buddy you're doing
great by the way the last donation was
specifically for you because apparently
someone took money from you at a poker
table in Vegas things got weird that
night but anyway they were paying you
back okay I'll give this one to you
Lawrence good game all right we're on
the school that was good technique just
gets us in the pole you know mm-hmm and
most importantly you beat the
Scandinavian in that game that's a big
milestone Geppetto just donated 50 big
ones we are at $3,100 there's two of you
to play some quality I say that as John
pushes the gpause quality test for the
next couple hours so that's we are
throwing this now we're playing chess
it's contagious okay all right now we
playing some chess
none of the Scandinavian crap sorry can
I just put my
see these these are old man slippers
right this is what happens when you buy
I gotta check out the camera so I know
what what kind of stuff
oh man slippers man those look pretty
comfy actually pretty comfy look at that
all right let's do it here we go mm-hmm
okay so this Bishop has bit rank so
we're just gonna move him huh
where do we move into John please mean
question hmm Jesus I know it weird you
know it's a bit ugly but we are
threatening some stuff right I'm just
gonna stick my queen on d2 and go from
there you are absolutely and so I just
don't I just disregard all of it I don't
give a flying do you know what yeah
let's get it on about this I'm not
scared
in the slightest I'm like a guy who
might have played the dragon at some
point so this oh I have played the
dragon I I am the dragon forget blame
the dragon hi Anna
Oh oh man this is getting forget
Khaleesi
the dragon of dragons I'm not sure about
85 e5 I think Magnus would call and move
from an utter fish but that doesn't
matter
let's take you just take that off you
deserve it yeah I knew you were gonna do
exactly this that's I'm quite quite
predictable you are very predictable
okay whoa whoa okay what oh nothing just
kind of struck me as a strange decision
well what do I do against Knight g5
sorry just thought you might try to keep
that light square Bishop 95 I'm not I
don't think so Meena Singh saw me no
seems so that's castle okay
you got to do what you got to do but I'm
sinner I'm not going to hate you either
way
really not you deserve everything you
get you just have the fame the glory the
chest university just donated $12 make
the Sun brown the boy now peers here's a
little message to all of you guys who
don't drink and are underage hit your
drink and do a stream at the same time
it severely affects your chess wise
words wise words from Lawrence let's
just polish this bottle off you know
they should polish him off Wow
rugby fires holy smokes this guy's bad
course gotta keep it consistent what the
hell is rugby five
like seriously dude you really want to
do this stuff to me okay you really want
to do that huh
guidance to want to do that something
god I want to do that so bad but I now
lose and I'll be sick what's the name of
this opening by the way cuz I'm Ches
calm it says open any defenses opening
is called malformation this is called
the Clarendon Court Clarendon Court
that's right that's a chest I found bug
fins I have known it the old gone Oni
mood you're not there for me I bet it
exists somewhere actually I shouldn't
say it's a bug this is the Clarendon
court named after the very famous place
in West London Clarendon court this was
actually dreamt up by a bunch of very
Lawrence I wait before you go are you
making this up or is this real
no this is real you seem serious this is
made up with the likes of David Norwood
Julian Hudson back in the 80s where they
were messing around drunk over bottles
of wine and and came up with it because
they played it in Clarendon court and
the name stuck so this is the key look
at this I mean look at this guy play
chess oh Jesus you're awfully excited
for a guy who's down two games I mean
for crying out loud this guy is just
hopeless I'm surprised I'm down two
games to be honest 17 minutes left in
the five-minute portion before we have a
quick break and oh do we have a break I
will take like a 30-second break give
you a chance to go out back and hose
yourself down
station identification will give John a
chance to confirm that his stubbl facial
hair is exactly the same length that it
was last week yeah and then we'll come
back okay I might disconnected I'm
lagging a little bit I looks like you're
both disconnected yeah disconnected is
what I'm showing disconnected bye
everybody
I'm not just gonna switch charlie let me
throw my lap did my last move register
Bishop d5
there's no it's nice the stream is
strong so we're still entertaining yeah
it's weird
hold on my game will also resign in 28
seconds I immediately uh reject that so
if I do a hard refresh just in case but
it looks like everybody's having the
same issue not you guys I'm not this is
not a lot just calm reload okay
considering I'm winning I'm not
defaulting this how do I do that shift
f5
yeah just refresh your page
we broke chess calm guys you did it it
was too much interest in this match hey
dude check out my streams Bronson we got
Charlie the ginger cat donating 20 John
he donated 20 for you to play a more a
gambit so I don't know if you want to
oblige that more yeah I play the
Sicilian absolutely Lawrence I recognize
that you're drunk behavior you're not
gonna make it till the end ok so we got
a lot of all kinds of fun donations
coming in buddy I'm winning this game
first stop so that's back to one then
we're basically even and then we start
again that's how it goes down what's
going on here Danny we're we're
struggling here yep we're struggling not
sure the position after 95
so we'll just restart the game we'll
just set up the game and then if we have
to I guess we can actually do that well
we have to have the technology to do
that believe it or not and rebuild we
can really I mean we just have to
rebuild here come on yeah we'll rebuild
and how much time was it when this
started happening well good I have 3
minutes 15 when I played mark and John
and his 35 what it's showing on your
screen
yeah
everybody using the chat now I've got
five minutes to check you out
everybody's slumbering in that kind of
stuff I love me able to roll back the
overall cut even love the trucks like
the live server is back
it says Lawrence trend one on time but
we're not gonna do that Mikey slice just
donated $5 check out Mikey slices stream
everybody one of our okay set it up set
this one up
indeed we are attempting to do so sir
so everybody trolling and whatever you
got to do in the chat I love you all
you're all sad little guys sitting there
with your Cheetos in your underpants do
me one favor follow me on Twitter I'm
close to 12 K boys 12 K and he's
verified he has a checkmark next to his
name so there's Nia and if you don't
follow me on Twitter please show my bags
show my bags - hi Evan you know just
shill um you know just buy and buy my
bags by my backs you know there are big
ones by there you know but I did
populous while you're out there Ben rx
Bible you know BMT you know just show my
bags while you're out there David
Sanders we have 35 minutes left I think
we're just gonna let the clock run for a
minute although I can I can pause it and
reset it um the live server is back
online are you guys back online I'll try
to get in here
I just tried to reload it it says too
many reloads though
please wait two minutes yep okay so
let's just wait a second and let's just
hang out with the chat for for two
minutes and okay the most loyal will
stay with us in the fans thank you by
the way this has been mind-blowing not
to say I bet against Lawrence and John
getting a ton of donations but no I'm
kidding oh i the the chest community is
amazing on Twitch we really appreciate
it and Lawrence I hope that you get a
small piece of this with your score
today that's all I can supply so what
are you talking about I'm
win this game that I mean with on one
game off I mean this is dream world
after the stop I had that's true well
we're gonna win the game we are gonna
restart the game we just got a $2
donation so people supporting us despite
wait but he said switch to Lee chess you
know what that's the most appropriate
thing to say when we are being ridiculed
by just calm bugs so that's the poetic
justice right there why have you got a
bunch of scam be followers acts
villainesses John Bartholomew I'm from
Norway part of Scandinavia
first are the fact that he has a [__]
point out that he's from Scandinavia
what do you things about the intellect
of your country he's he's supporting you
school and then he writes something in
Norwegian are you Norwegian I might have
some more Norwegian ancestry yes and I
was recently in Norway I played a couple
tournaments over there and Oslo and
Stavanger so you know I probably have
some Norwegian fans out there hey John
I'm from England body Europe geez
you know oh and you treat your followers
well they feel like they're part of the
team's candy community so when I end up
coming back in doing the business mmm
wait and go ahead nothing when all up
those intestines and I'm gonna be
exploring believe me and I'm on [__] his
head fall off should we get the surgical
gloves out let's get him out me and him
on could has a mouth or not you because
he's Canadian I don't like you could
remarried them we are gonna double-team
you like never before but if you've seen
the chest broadcasts its na you they
have matches like that so I think I
think the chest bras are in my corner I
love the chest bras
they're great back on the server Danny
sweet what's going on here we all are
everybody can get back on I'll be really
game clock to 15 minutes but trying to
make sure we can restart the position
with the same one that was left before
we get started so don't rematch each
other yet okay
I I'm excited to resume this mu jonah
formation game I mean you're only a pawn
down and completely lost but hey what
could be worse
welcome I mean I'm down upon you shook
aliens no are we even what's happening
with this pawn on f3 you're educated man
Lawrence you gotta count the pawns I see
five versus five what about this mornin
it free that's gone
we'll see you on Cassie oh we shall see
you
how many viewers we got we're at 3,500
oh my god 3450 can I share the link let
me click my messages because I'm sure I
go Greg Hardy doing something
well prior to this match Florence was
saying that he wanted to tank his chest
doc operating in order to gain as many
points as possible against me this is
and I was welcoming that idea because
one of my goals for this match was to
get his rating down to his ECF level so
I was hoping those ratings would like
match up his chest common is EC yet by
the end of the match but I got it win a
few more games to do that to be honest
buddy I'm quite confident that this game
I won't lie to you I feel pretty good
about this position okay are you know I
do feel good
I think there's everything to play for
why and why is everything tanking today
just out of interest
why is my portfolio looking might like
my chest comScore well so are you taking
after hikari oh you got into trading
you're a big finance guy I mean now I've
got into crypto about a year ago
slightly over maybe and yeah been been
doing that for a while kind of been
going okay could always be better but
you know can't complain
sounds like you a lot of time on your
own well I you know unlike new John
actually had a job for many years you
know I wasn't just saying they're bad
streaming all day
I actually went got up and went into the
office ball on the tube with everybody
else who's was miserable and then after
five six years I said you know what I
think that's enough then I decided to
turn my hand to the world of chess and
so far it's going wrong pretty good
pretty happy are you managing anyone
these days
sorry are you managing anyone these days
[Music]
oh okay hmm not at this time I mean no
comment at this time
when the time were to come I would I
would feel that information yeah what
what's going on with you know so how
many were at Ellis's could you imagine
being in the cue ball next launch
telling don't lie I know you've been
there buddy and know you've been there
so don't give me that stuff
so we just playing a five-minute game
from here
okay that's great no I'm more than that
Oh 315 to 235 for me oh okay all right
relax Lawrence you'll get your time
advantage don't worry yeah I mean that's
just like that we're off we good still
waiting for this time to us I still see
the times yeah my time is ticking now
but it says 4:35 you could always like
let it go
oh yeah no it's already adjust in our
art so just make a move oh there we go
oh okay there we go we're back we're
back boys and we're back and I'm gonna
reset the total game clock to 15 minutes
if that's okay with you guys do it go
for it so you have a few more minutes of
five minutes to make up for chest comms
incredulous behavior be my what
hopefully it's gonna let me make moves
that would be unfortunate yeah I think
it's working out this is good okay
London hopefully might have I have to to
make a move I have to do it twice Danny
ah it's is that happening to you
Lawrence oh no yeah we should abort
abort one of those games
abort the game I mean what's going on
buddy one second there's like two games
going because I ended up getting a
million staff members to help me because
somehow nobody was paying attention and
then everybody started a game at once
that's what happened
I think Lawrence isn't so happy about
his position anymore so I'm fine
he's hoping we can abort this one well
we might have to abort it at this no the
game is on play the game with less time
may play the game at less time yep
that's the time you guys had play the
game with less time okay all right um
play the game time to play the game all
right we play what making a move and
it's not going that's the point
Danny I'm making a movement and I have
to input it twice I know K now it's six
now it's fixed it says aborted for me
now yeah and the other
game is still going oh I see okay I got
it this first one how can i okay
which one am i play hopefully it's this
one make a move John so I can see okay
we're badge to play that okay I think
we're back so I think we're back should
be back we're back to see a wizard
I saw it I saw it that's what we call
the good move just so you know
mm okay John I hope you don't make a
drawl here make me really upset
I got a go for the W in this game you
going for the table T of course I got an
ass like my chances look I mean you ever
every we have a study chess before your
position stressful okay just one oh yes
we're watch that g8 square
supposed to be like impressed oh I'm
watching g8 don't worry about you are
not making me on GA today believe me
just making sure I want you to look out
for your best interest Laurens under you
are you or you're a good guy you know
despite what they all say you're
actually a good guy yeah despite the
negative press
you're in a bit of a bite here mi would
you agree
I guess I'm completely fine I'm just too
weak to understand why
um do you think you're better here
because I this is the weirdest spa I
think I'm bad I don't know I think I
definitely like my position really yeah
they're interesante
that was German and Spanish at the same
time hmm why do you like your pathetic
position here just out of interest I
mean I mean for real for real dog
yeah it seems pretty good still okay
I'm curious about your next move I think
the next move will determine a loss
right now on Rick aged five fun you
think I'm that dumb to fall for that
nonsense you got to be kidding me bro
all right you know what we're going in
boys we are going in hollering holla at
your boy
you
Hollan mm hmm hmm tempting options you
got a few options here
I'm just promised if I fall for up to be
eight made at any point um you know it's
not going to be particularly pleasant
right
okay Bishop e5 is a move of an absolute
yeah I should say you're just so lucky
that you've got that it's insane so
we're gonna just gonna you know we're
just gonna hang out we're gonna hang out
here
that move for a start
oh wow ooh oh my god
No are you for real are you actually for
real
that just or know about that decision
all right off we go yep got a run for a
run
okay that's frightening mate no what is
that from
what is that actually threatening
okay show me Chuck
oh my god it is I see some problems here
Laurence it is turning may I see a few
problems oh my god I hate my life right
now I think you had I think you had to
try something other than Knight takes c3
like rook takes a five it was really
before that missing e5 rook f2 and 83
it's a little dangerous
on 93 93 there instead of that was good
okay so we're in kind of we're in a bit
of a rut you do a great buddy I don't
feel great about that one under the
circumstances I mean I feel like your
concentration was disrupted more than
anything I think it started your issues
started when you miscounted the pawns
yeah probably
okay to wear all my issue start you guys
can rematch whenever you're ready so is
this the last five minute game darling
you have eight minutes and what is it
now eight minutes and thirty seconds or
so thirty seconds so very probable that
this is the last five minute game mm-hmm
that was actually a bit of a bit of a
bad game to lose actually if I'm totally
honest yeah you had that one racing
koala
you're pretty good about racing koala
wants to know what your coffee choice is
John uh so I like either straight iced
coffee or I also like iced espresso I
always go with the ice drinks even in
the dead of winter just my thing classy
yeah where is this h3 move that looks
very slow
probably it's very slow I just saw you
know put the bishop on the long diagonal
how bad can it be
yeah wow you're just ruthless you know
you're just a ruthless ruthless guy a
ruthless gentleman would you say no a
horrible human being okay I'm really
drunk now let's think this is the bad
part I can't see you right now I can see
you on like the Chester or that the
twitch broadcast but I feel like I'm not
getting the full effect you're not
getting the full of thing I've done
amazing things in this state before I
[Laughter]
don't think either one of you is getting
the full effect of something so for the
record I mean to be honest I've
definitely had worse positions I guess
let's try and like get this back to like
for an hour good let's keep it a like a
two-game advantage that would be kind of
swell you like saying swell where you're
from right that's gonna us I don't think
so no that's like a folksy down south
thing maybe 40 years ago but okay maybe
Dani can confirm that's right it'll be
swell daddy that Giffen exactly it's a
down south swell swell swell kind of
thing gee golly that d5 honestly Tommy
that would be just swell why do my
positions always suck um these are there
are so many great quotes from this match
today I mean it's just that is gold
right there I'm real I mean what the
hell is this all about
we can have to retreat someone in the
chat just called you an uncultured Brit
that's that's pretty vicious that's
vicious especially cuz Brits are usually
assumed as having culture yeah exactly
so I haven't I didn't confirm with a
British person prior to this match I
probably should have but what do you
think Danny I think Lawrence has a posh
accent would you say it's hush yeah it
is a bit posh and it's well I can't even
think straight like he sounds like he
went to a primary school and you know it
was raised in a very wealthy part of
London well you made up for it you're a
good actor okay I'm really at a loss of
what to do here guys so any thoughts
just saying in the chat let me know what
I should be doing in this position you
should probably get your night out on g1
do you think so I mean given that it's
only got one square that that doesn't
look particularly promising yeah giving
you a move right now
okay I just can't do this Knight g3 is
what you come up with okay okay now I
know how a parent feels when he plays
Magnus yeah that that hurt ouch cut to
the bone - all he calls a pretty high
compliment - I got a say okay that's a
nice compliment you paid me this match
given that I don't understand man oh no
no no no this cannot possibly work well
I mean what do you want me to do I'm
weeping for your dark squares right now
Lawrence what the hell that's a that's a
bridge too far I understand but what
that smug Oggy you know don't know if
you do understand though I do understand
just that's oh and it's bad news I ain't
denying it right there ain't no denying
that this is bad news
you're gonna straight write it huh I'm
gonna have to this is really bad
holy feel like I can't even like trap
your queen somehow but I'll just play
for checkmate I think you should because
I'm getting smoked here I think your
next two moves are forced yeah it's not
that one right that one knows the first
one that was forced yes I think I think
we have a few what me and my friends
like to call issues here we're gonna
have to define ants like nobody has ever
defended in their life to say yes go
I mean this is gonna have to be a
defense of such proportions that I don't
even think I'm defending I think I might
resign hey I'll give it to you I was
going to play c4 but yes okay if you
want to resign I'm just gonna resign so
play c4 in our resign
yeah I like c4 I like c4 as well given
that your positions completely winning I
mean I was thinking about like moving my
bishop and trying for Queen c3 but I
don't want you to play Queen d2 so so
you're not a man of your word
not going to resign I can't resign
because it's just too sick to resign all
the time again just bluffing huh really
just disgust
I mean I told you when you gave up that
dark story even I'm on next to me in
tears like for real I mean can I even
continue here I guess I can't continue
it right I guess I'm just wasting time
that's a pretty big discovery let's get
let's get one more 5-minute oh we still
got time yes we do okay you know let's
get one more 5-minute let's see if I can
do some damage here let's do it let's
play this again cuz that was fun this
will this will definitely be our last
five minutes we got that donation I'm
thinking of you and I'm going to go
ahead with it it was uh sorry I don't
remember everyone who's made a donation
today whoever made that Smith more
donation donate another dollar so we can
see your name but we've at the break I'm
gonna get a coffee
I'm gonna sober the hell out watch some
water on your face I told you we're
gonna give you just enough time to go
outside use the hose do what grandpa
Willers would do and shove your head
into a bucket of water and I don't know
I guess we play for mate right he's
playing for tricks already some people
wondering hey some people wondering what
our speed chefs algorithm that we've
been using to predict the the live odds
of some of the best players in the world
said about this match we can tell you
that the pre-match algo said that John
was a plus two favorite by two games but
we have not taught the algorithm to
calculate for wine yet so if our
algorithm gets off the hook today if the
score is more than plus two by John or
Florence can turn it around we'll see I
think it was Charlie the ginger cat who
asked for the Smith amaura thanks to my
team helping out there the time is up
five two is officially over though this
I wanted to go but I'm so snake-bitten I
can't even play it you know hmm yeah I
know that feeling man
the real me no job chest says nobody
should ever say the word algo is that
because it sounds too much like argh
argh oh and then we think of Ben Affleck
is that it I don't even know I thought
it was a cool thing that kids do like
they shorten words I'll go and yes and
what's your what's your sitch for
situation and well I don't know your
daddy pretty hard right now Danny I'm
dating it out dad it up I think I'm
doing all right for a Smith Maura I
don't play this but yeah let's just say
you know the books just say do that
right that's what the books say hmm
right yeah I I mean I didn't that's what
the books say you know we need Marquess
Herrmann here
he's the authority I mean am I just
gonna go mad here and do that and feel
sick when he beats me probably g5 yeah
yeah why not I'm gonna do it I mean it
looks the medic it looks pretty somatic
to me secure that square on e5 for the
night mm-hm
are you ready to tap out is that what's
got it hour
we've got an hour and a half left we've
already done more than a normal death
match would would allow I mean just you
know with the 15 minutes of chess calm
bugs hash tag story of my life Lawrence
Trent just donated $5 felt bad for
getting paid for this I don't know who
that is if that's actually your account
or someone donated $5 on your behalf
Lawrence Trent said I felt bad getting
paid for this so I'm gonna donate $5
myself that one that might be the
donation of the day right there what
happened to the hour 45 left who's Danny
Tanner Todd and even can we talk about
the a low 45 that's remaining rather
than the hour and a half what does the I
don't know we already we've already
given you your more time you have an
hour and a half of well it's actually
now we're not
game time you have more than that
because theoretically every second of
this game is in overtime right now and
it's not going against the total clock
don't worry Laurent occasionally wow I'm
gonna let you play 93 if you want to oh
my god now the last time this will
happened I've got in a tremendous mess
and but maybe he's not good enough to
block me twice huh okay let's have a
little thing here let's actually at the
time people ask me how I don't know who
Danny tanner is a Danny tanner is the
guy from what show is that home
improvement yeah is that Jonathan Taylor
Thomas Oh John I remember the guy from
the tool tool Tim Tim time oh yeah
apparently it's a full house though well
now okay one of those you know 90s
sitcoms yeah I'm trapped in a 90s sitcom
so I buy that I guess we've noticed we
know this what is it for enough ivanov
you're right you're down five and a half
one and a half buddy [__] on and off
all rights don't worry too much about
the score I'm kind of concerned about
the score it's gonna win on the board
for that let's finish off the five
minute well you know hmm
let's get to 4000 viewers everybody
let's make up for that bump in the road
we hit yeah tell your friends let's make
that chat lit or whatever it does when
it gets hot in check Hamid
I love playing the dorkiest dad in the
world though I mean seriously I do try
to look awkward so thanks for noticing
guess I really want to exchange Queens
here like this is where Magnus would
just be really really strong right no
all I had to do was make a CTA call to
action we got 4k peeps I'm very mean I
feel sick about it but I'm doing it so
whatever you know all right yeah I ain't
impressed by it I understand you know it
does look pretty disgusting
I mean I am a pullin up though right yes
okay so I know you're trying to do stuff
to me I know you're trying to do stuff
you're just gonna run huh I'm not gonna
run she's gonna block look like a
Frenchman see this is where I feel like
you drop one of these thematic 95 moves
yeah I think I should drop 95 at some
point but let's uh give you a check
first and see what happens
somehow it was a false alarm though we
crossed 4k viewers and right back down
to 3400 so I think it was one of those
like hype buttons but forget 4k viewers
let's get to 4k in dollars everybody
these guys need to be paid for the Sham
mockery they are putting on here today
they need it these guys need to get paid
for this fiasco
the shame on sir I should be paid for
the ordeal you're half the time I just
mute my mic and have to sit there and
look at people hate on me you know any
different chat rooms so you guys are
lucky I'm sitting through this rope
let's go
where's the tie little let's go
it wouldn't be a scandi or not a scandi
a Smith moral without this particular
move Oh crying out loud
this is a juicy position right here yeah
juicy goosy yes seriously I mean
Lawrence I blacked out like an hour ago
watching your chest I mean seriously
good and now that's coming from somebody
who has taken a public show walking from
time to time via John Bartholomew I
somebody watch the Ben Feingold for
Simon Williams man that's somebody who
had to sit through Ben Feingold Williams
which was I mean I that's four hours of
my life I will never get back Marty now
with lawrence lawrence through net
you're better than this Lawrence I'm
gonna reach through the camera and give
you an old slapper Oh Lawrence you're
better than us but that Williams much
come on that was something else man
oh it was just it was gross yeah that
was the most disgusting chest I've ever
seen hmm
that was just gross we need somebody to
get that donation party started i'ma go
check in on the chest TV show thank you
you still sane enough to like try and
work with Kay Jade here but I'm just you
know I'm just gonna do this because I
can't see anything you know
I understand okay I know you've got a
follow-up here so just do it and just
put me out my misery Charlie the ginger
cat just donated $5 for 95 that was very
Smith Morra
of you John so he's proud of you oh
thank you I try I think that was if
that's Charlie the well I don't know if
that is son of course but he's gonna go
for it oh my god
what I'm missing everything whoa no
we'll try
you
you for real I don't get it all right
well I've only got one move so whatever
I'm just gonna play it
so this was your idea huh
just maximum open lines wow you are a
flaming genius I'll tell you that that's
how you got to play this opening I think
if we take it what's good in current got
to play the opening this way I don't get
any of this but I'm gonna give you the
benefit of the doubt cause I'm playing
so bad all right
no I'm winning this position I'm not
losing no no he's coming back look at
that energy look at the energy
transferring in I mean okay whatever if
you've got it you got it really what I
mean what dude oh my god
holy cow I miss that well I mean I don't
know how much time so it's possible I
can miss calculate this definitely yeah
no that's just a winner
is it Oh
it's just a winner yeah I didn't have to
plate that right that's the sick part
about the whole thing I didn't actually
have to play that that one actually has
tilted me a bit got to do it for the
donation
it's just over him I can't that's
checkmate soon oh my god Knight f7 just
lost I'm sure I was winning there I
don't know about me yet Knight f7 was
problem yeah I know now I have seven
losses but if I go rook a seven there
yeah rook a seven Queen h6 and I can
take g5 or maybe take e6 next move Dani
are we on break now yeah I'm looking at
the analysis as you guys are talking
about Queen h6 rook g7 but we are on
break let's take a couple minutes we've
already had a break and I don't want
these viewers to go anywhere so you guys
both go go get yourself some ginger
whatever you got to do freshen up okay
alright I guess they're gone which means
I have to put myself on camera oh no all
right well it's been it's been quite a
wild ride if this is the kind of thing
you're into awkward jokes just calm bugs
funny self-deprecating humor from
Lawrence Trent and an absolute thrashing
by John Bartholomew of regular day's
work in chess TV I would say but I want
to thank everybody for being here dead
serious this is amazing for chess so
regardless of how anybody feels about
this format about anything just the fact
that you're here watching and we have
two professionals okay as much as you
can call these two professionals being
able to get donations and pay chess at
play chess have all of you contribute to
that I just want to thank you seriously
I mean it's amazing something that I
never really thought would be possible
and is pretty cool so we are it to
$3,200 if you're just tuning in all of
that money is going to the players we
appreciate all the support all the subs
that for what we do here at the twitch
TV slash chess channel just calm TV but
all that money's going to players so
let's get to 4k before the show's over
come on tell your friends how fun it is
to come over here and whatever I mean
Lawrence's Lawrence is here he's not you
know he's maybe not in his best shape
right now but he's here
the cranberry sauce
there you go cranberry it's good for
your bladder it cleanses things just so
you know I've got I've got some good
cranberry cleansing stuff here too just
so you know I'm not totally full of it
right my life those natural medicine
gals you know I'm gonna need a wiry I'm
gonna need a riot right you know I'm
gonna need some dry it this three plus
one I mean yeah you are you're gonna
have to make your stamp here and now
anything's possible in bullet I like to
think that but though don't tell the car
with that but I think you have a chance
right here right now Lauren so I'm gonna
put myself back off-camera my team is
gonna start the games root aboot now
good luck everybody hold on I just want
to see I'm just looking at the analysis
know you're winning after roots a c5
you're just a genius hey sometimes it
works out you were just winning okay are
we ready to go here we go let's do it
this is Gary plus one now yeah let's
toss one okay I'm sticking with the
bread and butter I know Greg Shahaji is
watching or probably he'll watch the
archive broadcast
he's very happy to see all these
Scandinavians I'm sure he's very hot
Robert from Australia is it 3 1 or 3 2
I'm pretty sure it's 3 2 dudes just FYI
3 2 okay I don't want you guys running
into any kind of confusion down the
stretch when wow I wish I actually prep
this if I'm gonna say did you like go
check out your preparation in that short
break they're open chef space I mean I
wish I knew that you did this stuff I
really do
I'm not even lying we just got a $5
donation routing for the riot Lawrence
they want a cut-off they want a close
match let's go let's go I ain't taking
this from some to do you know white you
know smiley white die nobody knows where
to go with that one so we're gonna move
on Lawrence was what is that well I just
landed a piece I promise you I have
I'm just lucky that it's only important
and not okay yeah you're lucky it's only
a pond so that's pretty good it's not
might not even be a pool and that's how
sick chess is that would be pretty funny
actually
how sick was it if I actually loved what
you into doing that and now this was my
plan or all the time okay so we can go
that way as well that way looks kind of
sensible just like one of those moves
you see you can't believe and I'm like I
mean that's just unbelievable maybe it's
that let's move it's possible all right
well we win that back which definitely
makes me feel a bit better about things
that's gonna help $10 donation there by
the way definitely helps we were we've
been are we referring to ourselves as as
in the third person we is not we is that
we have seen the enemy we have seen the
enemy and they are us
we is us okay I'm not taking I'm not
taking no more SHhhh
you know what I'm saying I ain't taking
gonna get motivated here
I ain't taking any more of it I don't
care I am taking any more of it
let's jump the pony in Wow
and Danny thank you for all the
vernacular that you've imparted on us
over the years I definitely incorporate
it into my commentary so I just wanted
to take this public opportunity to say
that just like it's just like one of
those traps where I say you're welcome
and then suddenly like you know like the
the I don't know no not at all no travel
no trap the vernacular that I have
introduced by being an idiot but thank
you
by the way I don't Danny just so you
know I think you suck I think you're
back the best way you belong so I type
some things I do I do I do said to bind
that death where I belong okay this is
where it could get really gross guys I'm
just letting you know in advance
anybody who's supporting me on a note is
very few of you don't think I haven't
forgotten you all there is an explicit
warning on this stream so you can be as
disgusting as you want I mean within
reason but yeah yes okay let me get is
like a buzzer where if they cross the
line guys like Trent and Feingold I can
buzz them and they get like a small
electric shock like you know one of
those little mini tasers that's a good
idea this is all getting a bit too
complicated for my liking yeah
[Music]
uh-huh well it's definitely not if we're
disconnected again by the way oh yeah
flashing flashing clocks so don't know
what you want to do about that how about
we just abort this start again and you
know say thank you very much it's been a
pleasure I'm starting to like my
position what's wrong
boy okay now we're back I think are you
back for ya no it's bought it's flashing
again refresh that I I'm not
disconnected so I don't know sorry
refresh okay what the hell is going on
Janelle says he reconnected but he lost
a bunch of time there how much booze I
lost like 30 25 seconds probably I'll
give it to you yeah especially because
we have we're gonna give you we're gonna
give you some time mr. Trent hmm well
this is not going to plan that being
said I've had worse positions Wow
that one I didn't expect we're treating
like a real Frenchman like a real
Frenchman this is like that other skinny
game where I was doing something against
her queen side not one I didn't expect
that's all Wow it's probably a really
good move as well which makes which
makes me feel even worse makes it all
the more sickening really does this is
just shades of the previous game really
yes I love it chats asking what Premier
League team you support Lawrence Chelsea
FC Geoffrey wherever I might be we are
ok now John's trying to get cute and it
doesn't ever suit him so punish him you
know let's really punish the guy hey I
was trying to get cute you're right
about that
you were trying to get cute it didn't
work out now you're in what we call a
rut a rut bit of a rut yeah a rut you
saying bit of a rut ok really
ok now I'm not going to Mouse lip this
what are you trying to do like you've
really miss played this I'm just going
to let you know this has been a severe
severe miss playing of the situation
just so you know you're just
positional for your own good I'm just
letting you know about that sometimes it
backfires on me I gotta say it really
does I can understand why
mm-hm what have you done to your
position like seriously it's still
decent I think but it definitely isn't
as good as it was before
not that Basin knowing calm down I mean
look at your pieces your rook is on h3
my piece is stepping on each other
Doug have you ever heard of the Nakamura
school of chess
yeah but I don't think you're the
ambassador of that
all right this is a cozy position kind
of a weird position yeah it's like we're
all big one happy big family they're one
big happy family as they say in English
yes
kind of a weird position right so I
guess I've got we're just gonna do that
anyway so I'm just gonna do it so
whatever it's expand I'm kind of a
really weird position mm-hmm
case you guys are wondering where I went
thanks for all the donations everybody
I'm just trying to be silent these guys
are actually playing a series of
consecutively quality chef's moves and I
just don't want to jinx it that's all
hmm
let's back off yes
I really don't want to draw again okay
we're gonna do this we're going for it
boys we have to win it's an all-out
situation you got a try right why did I
just do that like really why did I just
do that that was some of the dumbest
stuff I've ever done in my life hmm so
lucky 'happy this is the weirdest
position in the world this is quite
strange I got to say the fact that I
can't take that ruckus tragic yeah that
was really nice have to sit have to say
gotta give a shout-out to fianchetto in
the chat if it's actually your birthday
Fiona happy birthday happy birthday
Fiona happy birthday
birthdays the only real holidays that
exist right
no nobody biting on that okay moving on
you try Danny crickets at some point you
just go to get going you know yes
Fiona's birthday's tomorrow but still
happy early birthday as I do not plan on
being on a stream tomorrow though we now
have valued the arena Kings tournament
coming up hmm so maybe I will be online
tomorrow I don't even know what I'm
doing
hmm yeah this is over all right I'm
gonna give you that one
Lawrence $20 donation just came in after
that win we are at 3,300 dollars and
there's a small outside chance that all
of it doesn't just go to John after that
big victory so way to go rematch guys
you're ready did you send me a rematch
yeah I don't see any there we go okay a
match questions on the arena King yeah
tomorrow we're holding our first ever
tournament with cash prizes for
non-title players first time ever maybe
in the history of online chess is that a
thing that's ever been done but the
prizes are focused on streamers so for
all those who enjoy playing arena
tournaments and would like to stream
their games you have a chance to play in
a weekly event with cash prizes for it
so there you go but five dollars in one
cent I love that for for your riot
Lawrence for the chance that you go on a
riot I might I might do it I've been
known to do it I'll promise you this
isn't some kind of you know some kind of
myth I have been known I'm just letting
you guys know straight up no funny
business Wow
you're such a fish whoever plays holy
cow
only an absolute amateur plays Bishop
III in that position
I just want to sack that I'm the one
second I am the sucker you are the sake
remember that you are Finn's the the
rock
thus candidate what the hell are you
doing man what is this you want to give
me the match okay I mean a mother pawns
as well you're a real genius you are
I feel recent about it you feel decent
about this you should be ashamed of
yourself yeah because your knight on b8
looks a little I don't care about my
idol I don't need that night you
understand I don't need it all right
maybe I'm in a bit of trouble but that's
besides the point
you know that's besides the point really
back to my true nature just try to trade
down yeah now you're just gonna try and
try it down like a Frenchman is it okay
that I'm stealing been flying gulls
lines I feel pretty bad about it that's
a bad sign the are spewing kiss lines
yes 94 alright so what's going on in
here John John boy Johnny boy John Stehr
just trying to generate some play attack
your d6 pawn are you attacking it
putting pressure okay I'm gonna play
like Frenchmen really you are well I
mean what to do I mean for crying out
that you know you like 66 you're you're
sharp I'm drunk you know I don't know
your roofs just surprised me sometimes I
understand when I say wow it comes from
a place of admiration
don't any funny business there shall we
first mm-hmm mm-hmm I mean I feel pretty
good about my position I don't know
about you but like it looks pretty
decent
Luc's Dixon right yeah you got the dark
squares doesn't look lost
right so Lawrence's standards it doesn't
look lost right yeah I don't know I'm
pretty bullish about this position
pretty bullish about it we all gotta
have hope somewhere right okay
so the first thing we do is that right
I'm willing to give you the B to par
Laurence but hold on a second you've
completely miscount all of this hmm
because you're a massive fish let me
just to calculate this that's got to be
a ridiculous move right now I know you
are giving me beat super I don't want
Peter you ever thought about that John
you ever thought that I might not want
what you want in this relationship um I
just like looking at the chat I'm
actually ahead on the clock in this game
this is surprising I feel pretty
disgusting about how things have
developed in this game I have to say I
definitely shouldn't have done what I
just did I'm really down on on time here
as well which is kind of gross I told
you okay okay I'm just gonna do this
when in doubt take a pool
and go for activity yeah just just just
okay just have it it's yogurt I will
take it I don't care about it you can
just have it you know it's a tasty one
now overrated hmm Wow I mean what am I
gonna do
I'm completely bust over here whatever I
mean again it's not it's not coming from
a place of criticism it's just surprised
okay well we'll take surprise I guess
it's just game over here right right
hmm
I guess it's just game over maybe not
after that move maybe that's a good move
okay let's get behind that guy okay you
get behind him you deserve it
mmm [__]
like words I never expect to be said on
Ches TV and then they just come out to
be concerned
I guess I'm what happens in my position
I think seriously the swings man swings
I mean seriously what happened cuz I was
I was doing really ok ok ok let's not
waste any more time actually somehow
yeah
Bishop c3 was a big mess on my part
rugby one Bishop a5 nineties and what
did I do
let's go Sicilian 95 that's when I made
the mistake with 95 I had to find a move
there what did i do rugby 8 and then you
in check yeah I had to go I had to do
something c4 or something I don't know
she's got to go out of the next hand
Laurens anyway just get on with stuff
you know right yeah you can't what do we
one hold in the three-minute one all in
the three-minute that's right ok
I don't know whatever Trevor okay I'm
gonna concentrate now like they've had
an hour and a half of banter so you know
they're okay for the moment yeah now
it's down to the real business now we
need to actually start playing some
chess here to to to give ourselves even
a smidgen of hope
I like the pair of Bishops you should
they're nice they are they are Wow God
he's so confident he can play moves like
that how sick is that really I don't
know if that's that great of a move well
we'll find out if it's good it's good
you deserve it you're a better player
well done Danny get him a medal ready
yeah or am I get him get him a medal
I don't think c4 deserves a medal thank
you you blossom
you always have counterplay I suppose
but yeah they play better it's the bat
you've definitely bluffed one too many
times
really you've bluffed just one too many
times here I think Finn's hey you know
what I mean
hmm
I know you got a decision here you think
about it
stick that way okay geez let's try not
now slip okay
now we need do a good move front okay we
are just going to do this like a
Frenchman okay well we're not completely
drawing dead here which is situations
within no not an audio should be you
should be ecstatic about this position
shout out to knows no wall who just
subscribe to our channel thanks for all
the subs and support let's get to 3,500
if Lawrence can hold this one hey let's
get to 3,500 anyway everybody yeah the
you for real are you actually for real
Freddie it's tragic
if this is just tragic what's going on
quick shout out thank you to all roughly
3,600 of you watching right now chesty
ve twitch TV slash chess and all the
support we've gotten hoping to get to 4k
for these guys today all donations made
go only to the chess players not the
government charity
Lawrence is on his way to donating five
hundred dollars to a charity is it a
charity of John's choice I assume the
winner gets to choose yeah winner gets
to choose that's what that means you'll
be making a thousand dollar donation to
charity cuz chess comm is already
matching that five hundred all our
donation least I can feel good about
something you should feel good about
that Lawrence that's a thousand dollars
to charity for what you did here today
I'm happy about that seriously I'm
honestly happy about that maybe that was
the one good maneuver I've done in two
hours
jeonju on the troll in this position no
I like this one right but you are
maneuvering nicely I gotta say I have to
say I'm slowly how many games can I win
into one minute I mean that's gonna be
kind of crucial right yeah yeah I'm just
not gonna think now I'm just gonna play
complete so I got 37 minutes of
three-minute here you are white in this
game you're I mean I'm less you're worse
but I'm worse you know but I've had two
aspas ition right yeah
crazier things have happened John is
good at bullet I don't know that John's
a monster a bullet right John how would
you categorize yourself as bullet bullet
um you know I haven't played one plus
one I like most im's you would say
better than Danny worse than a Mon that
would be your classification of yeah I
mean it this is one plus one so I don't
know how I would fare in that but
regular bullet I'm pretty good yeah it's
always a game changer with the increment
yes
the deathmatch fund everybody is the
initial prize fund courtesy of shechem
and our glorious sponsors was two
thousand dollars a thousand dollars to
the winner 500 to the loser and 500 to
the charity of the winners choice but
courtesy of all of the support we have
received from all of you on Twitch today
we now have thirty three three thousand
three hundred forty six dollars and one
cent that money
is every every every dollar we've
increased is going to be split by these
players so nice of somehow managed to
get something going in this position you
know yeah getting some play indeed and I
know I'm worse Wow okay yeah I don't
know if you're worse actually now you
don't think I'm worse here I don't know
this one is hard to say
Hey
let's jump in see what happens okay I'm
just gonna give a check to it
you gotta try it a spite checking with
nothing else so like I thought here that
I had reasonable chances of winning this
this is where Magnus would just be
brutal you know yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
wuss out okay
back to when she came oh my god I'm
super lucky okay still everything to
play for here absolutely no idea what's
going on here Eric just donated a
hundred and fifty dollars I don't know
if that's our that's our that's our CEO
Eric right there oh okay
Eric the CEO and founder of chess calm
donate hundred fifty and said Danny
can't beat him a CrossFit that is that
is that is actually true Eric is a
monster at CrossFit but I do lift some
things heavier than him for the record
aha
I know you're really into when I talk
about CrossFit John that's like your
favorite thing you're like Danny we got
CrossFit more I get quite excited
whenever that topic comes up kind of
disgusted with how the past few moves
have gone if I'm totally honest it's
another one of these positions where
it's like unclear who is messing this up
or who's better my
I mean I don't feel great about how I'm
handling it either
this is uh probably pretty know when you
go to pause pool and just push it what
they say ooh baby baby baby baby ooh
baby baby baby nurse I know one and just
like that do you
Lawrence trail we got a second decisive
game hey somebody get us over 3500 after
that hundred and fifty dollar donation
you talking about oh you've won three of
mine I was so seen if I was seeing how
many you've had thank you for passing my
chest don't shortchange him on his total
that's right but okay anyway let's get
over 3500 peeps let's do it practical
chess just subscribe thank you for that
and John you should tell everybody about
that work that CrossFit workout I put
you through and did it but was that what
you actually do that I was in hating on
giving you a CrossFit workout but that
ever happened about the camp in Arizona
that oh my god the delicious bass just
donated $10 and we are officially over
3,500 Lawrence as much as you're
enjoying that the total time clock is
ticking away your chances at a comeback
I'm waiting to put a clip on rematch the
game rematch ten minutes ago no no click
new 3+2
huh oh wait okay I'm gonna match again
challenge fails it says okay let's let's
do a rematch here and you pulls the time
clock because that's that's not fair I
was waiting it's only a few seconds for
blood
when you've got a past form just push it
there we go
what's going on with that somebody
somebody's watching the show yeah that
was me I'm just checking out that last
clip thanks for it was that much okay
I'm bored of giving you palms John the
donations are coming in now there have
been guys both and in good spirits here
well you have as a mich as image that's
it oh no no we've got we've got an opera
box a mich actually turns out they call
it what is it what is it this beachy
vibes Danish I don't know it's like the
Matthew Sadler specialty it's good for
blitz whatever it is you know tio tio to
Aki said he will donate again when
there's a big blunder he just donated
$50 you guys can thank him for that
although when I can encourage you to
avoid blunders for your own chess for
the purposes of my the entertainment of
all of us here who are who are I don't
want to say strapped to the chair here
but that's how I feel problem is that
our dissection right now strapped to the
chair how dare you that's somebody I
think I could hand off these hosting
duties for future death matches by the
way I can tell everybody that we've got
some exciting we've got some exciting
matches coming up this year for blitz
death matches so we've got more of this
more of this type of format coming up
with I don't want to say just who yet
Lawrence you know - but let's not say
yet not yes well don't want to spoil it
okay so we've given up the poem 4-0 comp
but you like the Brico gambit so much
last game you try to do it this game -
yeah right I was somebody put that on a
t-shirt so I've given up a pawn 4-0 comp
but dot dot dot there's always a silver
lining that would be that would be a
good t-shirt all right
I'm constantly frustrating Eric with my
goals to just put chess phrases on
t-shirts ending us remind me like Danny
we're not in the chest t-shirt business
that's not what we do but I think
there's a lot of great chess TV shirt
test TV shirt lines the we could come up
with yeah that could be a booming
business you start putting your your
phrases on there yeah I mean you're into
it right I mean I know there's little
bit of sarcasm there but I mean I'm here
for it generally a six Wow
spit out there right it is I do like it
something is just as well a different
screen and I am and a GM not the way we
play a giganteus sort of chasm in real
terms not very much maybe good I mean
look if I'm an Hambleton is GM shouts my
boy
Amnon goes from the the beardless wonder
which is what did I tell you guys that's
what Magnus called him before we went
live with the speech yes the beardless
wonder it was awesome it is whining yeah
before before midlife for the speeches
cuz we ought to hang out in zoom Magnus
and Hikaru and hanging and Eric and Amon
were in and out and and Magnus who
apparently pays attention to him on
Hamilton's career which is a complement
in its own right yeah
gave his best wishes and congrats to the
to the now beardless wonder that's
pretty funny I've got no idea what's
going on in this position but you know I
don't think if I'm totally honest that
Jon has either which is no I definitely
don't feels completely unclear to me I'm
quite confused right now I do want to
take some pawns though you can chill
right you got the right to fight the
right to fight to party all right Tommy
she'll be donated said if they saw Danny
in a chess t-shirt you stuff him into a
locker which is not a bad idea I've been
locked in a few lockers in my life
but Jeff's t-shirts man chesty Beatty
shirts look out they're coming yeah this
definitely hasn't gone as planned last
couple of moves be honest with you um
then we have to take that which is
extremely sad this is this is getting
more and more sad by the Trump would say
sad you know sad
damn mr. sad this is really this is
really sad folks see that guy well will
will hit your queen yeah yeah but about
the I imagine thing someone once told me
that the only difference difference
between irons and GM's is that all irons
want to be GM's and no GM's want to be
AIIMS
net everything is the same it was a
great line I don't know who gave you
that but I think it was Alejandra
Ramirez actually that's that's a handi
ism yes he doesn't have many bright
spots that we remember in those moments
[Laughter]
$3.99 for Maurice Ashley in Central Park
playing chess that's a combi Maurice I I
don't think it is but it seems like it
should be a Washington Square Park thing
not not Central Park one thing you guys
are doing is convincing a lot of people
they can make im2 so I will tell you
there is there is that that you guys are
doing here providing hope you know so
I'm up to pawns here but they're not
very good pawns right yeah but that was
really stupid yeah that seems to invite
exactly what I wanted yeah yeah big more
than that I would say in fact my
original idea was not to allow you to do
that was a generous generous idea now
we're in real
Shh we're in real deep now rolling in
the deep' we're gonna give a chat and
rolling in the deep' mm-hmm it's pushing
baby
yeah you should push on baby
crime correction too weak too slow
little peasant was not a damn good
bullet player back in the day he still
is a great bullet player and everyone
remembers little peasant from ICC mom
what's going on here with the rooks
that's a really good move that's upset
me that's actually upset me a bit you
know I have to try hmm I missed it I'll
be honest with you I did miss it
mmm-hmm get some annoying defensive
resources though I really do huh yeah
like how did that happen okay I just
like think I have to take that right I'm
just not even in the thing about these
maps now Chris Wow
and I'm not sure what to say about that
uh-huh okay whoa maaaah
this is suddenly very very weird yes
sugar sugar and maluca like who's
playing for the win here yeah okay time
to do this move hey doing that whatever
I don't know
okay see what happens here well I guess
it's a draw but yeah it looks like it
okay so that was really interesting what
what are you doing I'm gonna play this
out six dollars and one cent from tio
tio T Walker Magnus Carlsen just
dominated $5.00 here's some money in
these rings oh no I'm serious cuz you
said it offered a drunk oh okay so that
was really exciting that game time you
found it again after rook b7 it was
getting getting weird you you were in
true I think you were thinking you were
you know he was getting a bit
troublesome for you there at some point
yeah cuz after that you can win my rook
if you want but yeah but then you go e 7
at the end
yes pawns are pretty dangerous right
getting some requests in the TV chat
that I one day host a deathmatch of
Danny versus uncle Sasha not sure how
that would work but I could probably put
there's no personality am i winning out
of the opening no oh the three-minute
portion you are up by a game sir so I'm
down three right you're down four what
you got some ground to make up man oh my
god I've got tons of ground to make up
how can I be down for games that can't
be right it's crazy as people say the
Danny versus uncle Sasha death matches
I'll remind you that alpha zero got good
by playing against himself so maybe
there's something to that
hey John would you commentate on Danny
versus uncle Sasha death mask just so
those two guys could focus oh yeah I
would love to
we're gonna go all out because uncle
sasha is one of your best characters we
didn't got anything to lose okay love me
better makes me happy makes me feel like
you Johnny boy you make me happy this is
like 80s
what is it that you wear are you coming
up with this stuff let's ask a man hey
mom do you like that track mmm
sure do mighty fine all right
a man's happy okay they're saying oh
don't don't quit my day job I listen
this is my day job they're they're used
to bad singing from time to time so oh
man
that being said I'm feeling pretty happy
about this I have to say if I'd known I
could get these positions I would be I'm
gonna have to make some ugly moves yeah
you really are you know what screw you
I'm going home
whoo all right all right now we're
playing one second that's clippable
remember now with game now we're getting
going be five okay okay that was
probably a bit ostentatious but maybe
it's a good news who knows could be it
could be could be complete rubbish like
I gotta take this
really I got to get my pieces out okay
is that how you describe getting them
out or is that okay hmm this is this is
one of the more fun games we've seen in
a while
you guys have piqued my interest here
I'll stop no I'm good it's good now I'm
feeling a bit sexy you know and you
dressed up in place and I'm ready to go
I'm ready to rumble definitely have to
avoid King d8
yeah the King would have been definitely
glad Wow if you get away
they'll feel sick
positively okay I can do that well
that's a queen
I really want to Castle by hand right
now King nicely tucked away on CA
preferably with a ruck on I ate some
like that we're gonna give you a check
see what happens
that seems fairly forced now we exchange
those guys and it's a question of
whether you survive or not that's really
that's really just a question isn't it
hmm maybe I just got 95 net wins so I
don't think I want that guy I actually
didn't see that the bishop was attacked
on g5 at first I don't think I want that
okay Danny knows I'm good at these
positions he's often commented on my
ability to slink away from an attack
Jian is a good defensive player he
really is it's one of the things one of
the best attributes of John game he's
got I don't want to call him a mini
Minister of Defense but he's got car
yakin principles in his chest there he
defends a lot of positions carjacking
instincts yep really okay yeah
wowsers right you are getting a good old
schooling my little friend are you sure
we'll find out oh that's a real donation
bar feeding master my client we got both
chat rooms popping right now whether
you're on twitch TV chess or chess calm
TV we got title players in the chef's
talk on TV chat he's shocked that you
guys have gotten that much money donated
today my god Mike that's what it is to
be an IM I'm just kidding buddy just
kidding
I see im's don't get a chance to be
proud of their title very often usually
they're the punchline this is a pretty
sick game boys whatever happens I'm
pretty stoked about how it's all kind of
yeah I agree
happen because I'll be on this video
it's it's pretty pretty pretty nice game
um yeah this is I don't even know what
the results gonna be but like I said I'm
I'm enjoying it mm-hmm Lawrence yeah
don't do that
did you see I just feel so sick to allow
you to do that right now just wanted to
make sure if see if you saw John like a
good a good coach Lawrence now Lawrence
I feel like I'm being disciplined by a
wicked stepmother now Lawrence h3h3
Oceana h3 meters they should be saying
like I was gonna do shout out to all the
premium members and title players in the
chest TV chat thanks for all your
support red thunder hard you're awesome
this is just so sick all right let's not
waste time I really felt I'm just gonna
can somebody analyze that one and let me
know let's get a donation one for a
Grand Master to analyze that game so
that Lawrence can learn from it no I
mean I felt like I was really close
there if I got Bishop e2 what happened
after we should be so you're gonna know
Queenie for that's what I didn't like h3
was looking good that's all I know
h3 there
yeah just play chess Bay are our chess
philanthropist strikes again donating a
sub to Greg Shaw hottie who is now a
trick Shahadah yeah Greg great the one
and only Greg hottie
okay I'm a bit miffed about that one her
somehow a lot more than the others
because it really felt like I was on the
roots of something special
could have been the start of Hampton you
could have been a contender I mean
that's the sort of game that Magnus
wouldn't have won but maybe some look
I'm gonna say one piece of advice here
buddy just a lot of things you've said
today maybe you should stop comparing
yourself to Magnus and worry because you
know what none of us are there but we
know I didn't realize that that's a
pretty high bar the Magnus bar just do
me now just end it I deserve it I'm a
bad person
you know that's let the self-deprecation
come roll out some down six now right
five really done five that Gill ass game
just took a long time oh my god I'm
basically from yeah you're not doing bad
just just a little roll a little two or
three game rolling we're back in it then
we're playing for something what are you
doing in this opening job on a serious
like this position so much I mean for
crying out loud
okay I'm gonna think here right I am
gonna take a moment why can't I just do
that just tell me why I'm just gonna do
that and if you beat me so beer I don't
care anymore beat you go if you beat me
so good you win
good luck well done boy chance gunshots
you know mmm yeah this is not looking
good
not looking good at all
hello a lot of lights core problems oh
[Laughter]
man we'll take a piece John you can you
can resign buddy there's no shame in
resigning
there's none at all I'd like to make you
prove it at least a little bit no don't
do it this one you've got you're better
than that
come on you're better than that mate
come on you're better than that also if
I resign it would be like a 20 something
move loss that's all right
you're better than this so come on you
know you this is ready
come on this is insane come on let's get
on to them let's actually show you know
your followers they really like you
you're a nice guy blah blah blah but see
your technique what take me I just take
a pool what they are you talking about
man yeah go for it okay oh no well if
you do mean this one it's I mean I'll be
honest with you it's it's it that'll be
very upsetting no no that that would
that will end it for me I mean this is
already like that's so easy anymore
right
no it's still okay I just got lucky I
just got really lucky I didn't deserve
to get lucky but I got lucky
b5 I don't know I'll pretend I got lucky
then if I didn't get lucky I'll pretend
it hmm
why didn't I go bishop c6 anyway just
out of interest bishop c6 I had some
stuff in mind you did yeah and if I do
it now mmm
you can still no I can still do it right
let me just actually spend a minute on
this
folks in the chat this is why you play
them out these games okay I'm gonna do
it anyway so whatever you make me you
make well done congratulations
hey I definitely could have done this a
bit better that I know for a fact
yeah let's try no I know and I'm gonna
feel sick if you I'm not gonna let you
play Queen a fake mate but I'm still I'm
just completely sick that the whole
thing I'm so disgusted with the whole
damn thing I'm not even joking I'm not
even joking how disgusted I earn right
now you don't even understand this is
actually pretty gross this is I'm really
upset right like as we talked about on
Twitter like I kind of feel well I'm not
even joking how upset its I don't have
to take a shower after this game yeah
and I know you you you should take the
show you should be all of us just take a
shower this is like watching saw or a
horror movie you just have to cleanse
yourself afterwards like what I mean yes
I mean this happened I'm not lying this
did happen so whatever guys you know
what is it just just do it and finish me
off and you know well no matter what
everybody in seven minutes or so we will
have bullet and we'll see whether
whether things get spicy I still have
hope that that somebody decides this
match is worth I mean one or more bucks
to get to 4000 really really I'll be
honest with you I mean it hurts it hurts
everybody everybody involved I mean for
real
hmm I mean for real guys
kinda think both our techniques could be
improved here really yeah this is this
is gonna be a fun one I'm excited
jae-hwa wants me to check if if John
Miss Mayton one let me go to the
analysis and check that ah that's very
possible given the way I'm playing this
well we've already had confirmation that
Lawrence was plus seven in the last myth
Morrigan but let me see I feel so sick
it's not even true I'm pretty sure he
didn't I think somebody thought your
Queenie six mover there would have been
made John but he the black always had
bishop of seven two Bligh yeah and after
taking it Lawrence stopped the mate with
f4 so pretty sure there was not a maiden
one hopefully that answers your question
there in the analysis board I just feel
so sick it's not even true so
see if I remember my debts key here is
this the rats key I mean whatever I
guess
Stover anyway so yeah okay yeah that's
that's just gross that's that that one
is too much
that was the realest candy swindle of
today yeah that was that was far worse
than the second game hmm
well scandalous as it may be you guys
still have another game to play here
let's do it four minutes in the three
minute portion before we had to bullet
that was too much it was too much I mean
you're you're on its hilt right now
you're on your own fool - well actually
you left tilt about an hour ago and no
no but but but come on that that's too
much that's too much that was pretty bad
no that's that's that's that's too much
come on guys that's just too much that
one you know that one was that one was
was hard to stomach mm-hmm
that one was really just too hard too
much to stomach for one evening
that one actually hurt me real deep
practical chest says now we know why
it's called a death mesh that's right
these things are not easy you know these
are grueling especially if you end up
being the one on the other side of the
tracks you know it's hard to it's hard
to stop the train when it's some rolling
in a negative direction let's talk about
Lawrence like he's not here everybody
let's observe what we're seeing in here
what you're watching is a chess player
on complete tilt without the time to
emotionally recover which is what makes
tournaments easier I mean come on I mean
really come on
right from now on I'm not celebrating
until I've won a match that is that is
probably the best advice you've given
yourself all day overconfidence he's
gonna do stuff to me here that's gonna
make me feel so gross with myself mmm
you know I think your hope your winning
the opening discussion in this weic
weick II I keep missing the name he just
donated another $50 as he said he would
donate again for a blunder so we're
gonna get oh okay I just know it I know
you guys are gonna get 4k I'm gonna be
shocked by lunders that's awesome
hey it makes it easy right it makes it
easy no pressure
feeling kind of good about this even
though I shouldn't feel good about
anything I mean oh not a porn so no a
pod classic Trent what is up with that
move just take it put me on a mystery
I want to see it we just got a donation
from one of our live chess architects
Peter donated $64 you guys are at 37 25
right now $64 I'm pretty sure knowing
Peter and the chest lover he is that was
that was specifically because 64 is a
good chest number name
is it does this work this is a weird one
I mean please let me win one John I'd
like to avoid that John is John's
ruthless man I've been until they
against him any rivals and and only
gotten worse me come on
I mean the guy didn't resign well I mean
it pays off right absolutely
you and I make losing winning positions
look easy
on and it is hard it is hard to lose
winning positions it really is if
someone donates 270 for 98 we are at 4k
but we can get there the old-fashioned
way too because the support here has
been amazing today I mean one of you has
deserved this support of getting
Lawrence you deserve you deserve I mean
I mean I played entertaining chess so
what is this I was kidding I was kidding
it's hard I mean here's the thing about
chess somebody has to lose every game
all right so no strictly true but plush
yeah you're right no actually right yeah
like this is what that ride job yeah
definitely this has been an interesting
I mean this sec yeah but x86 ok we're
not blond drinking h7 so whatever but
are we still worse how can we always be
worse like for real okay whatever I
don't know that you're worse here am i
no I don't think so
but you asked me you asked me again in
30 seconds yeah exactly that ladies and
gentlemen's bring gentleman's ladies and
gentleman's Wow
that brings us to the end of the
three-minute portion okay
there's no sponsors no masterclass
sponsorship here so the garry kasparov
trailer has officially been implanted
into everybody's psyche
well has +5 ever been achieved in the
Blitz before in the Serena Bullet to
come back at one time one time plus
minus 4 has but has has been come back
hey why can't I speak all of a sudden I
people have come back from - for a
couple times but - 5 was a a single
match it was Irina crushes comeback
victory and that's in the traditional
deathmatch format a traditional
definition format indeed okay that was
before the SCC the speech has
championship was a thing okay
I mean I shouldn't be worse here by Jung
I don't know this is I mean I like my
position but really you have the three
minor pieces minor pieces that was a
really dumb move by the way
and I actually played what I wanted to
play then trying to create problems for
your night mm-hmm shout out to Steve is
five who's just been making a ton of
clips like a true oh gee is that
something the kids say oh don't tell me
that means he's is that a cool thing to
say John oh gee John you're my cool
Peter you're letting this ball do G is
good okay you're here for me to remain
cool okay oh gee Oddie's I'm losing you
again
forget the og meter this is the owe me
oMG I think what you're doing right now
is you're being Oh Pete you're being
John is okaying you I didn't watch that
broadcast where Eric introduce you to
that term that's right that's right this
is just the most disgusting chess got a
nerf ins someday I hope it you know
retire and I'll just do streams all day
on my own little concern I'll learn all
these o gops and Baba Dee's just put me
off chests forever Lawrence it's it's um
actually I don't know I'm speechless
yeah
I mean this has just put me off chess
forever for real how do we got this is
the last game right so I should just
play on right yeah this is the last
bullet after this it's not the last game
of everything there are control now I'm
just so sick of this
right Odie is not Opie is not to be
confused with OPP who everyone as you
know is down with you know me OPP sorry
I got that reference Danny okay but Oh
boom let's just get better Run DMC okay
okay
it's weird out of here and go wash
yourself off Lawrence come back in 30
seconds when we have no Jon needs a
quick break Jon needs a quick break all
right I'm just gonna get some water
everybody take 30 seconds of breather
I'll say hi to the fans cuz you know
apparently I don't need to go anywhere
hi everybody
Wow well this is going down I I think we
need to have a poll on whether this has
been more of a trainwreck than the
Williams fine go where Simon really just
lost his his marbles he lost his marbles
like the guy from hook right thanks for
the donation there seriously again
everybody this has just been phenomenal
the opportunities that chess players
have now online is just awesome and so
we feel super thankful and fortunate to
all of you that it seems that all we
need to do these days is bring and bring
some people together provide the
platform and and all the support is
coming here just it's so awesome
seriously and we appreciate it so much
Lawrence and John appreciate it I I'm
not sure I appreciate it that but no I'm
kidding I do
Lawrence you look a little bit wildered
I'm not gonna show you on camera till
you're ready are you focused I'm ready I
just wanna you are what I'm ready you're
ready you might want to mute me cuz
there's gonna be an echo coming back
here okay so enter enter CCC we did in
Aronian sorry I'm answering chat
questions while John's gone we did that
Aronian play Grichuk in this
type of match oh you mean with trash
talk
Oh Aronian grisha trash talk now that
could be the bees the bees I want to get
I want to get Magnus up in this kind of
trash talk what do you guys think all
right well don't do it let's get the
bull I'm tired of being on camera
I'm gonna go back to muting myself here
in the corner
sticking with the repertoire yeah the
main line D for stuff no but like I said
you've been crushing me in the
theoretical battle in this match yeah
that's true so I hope you can take that
away with you oh I didn't mean to do
that I actually dragged the night and it
didn't do it for whatever I'm serious
okay so how long have we got of this
portion I think it's 30 minutes only 30
minutes
I mean hopeless you know even if I won
every game no it's never hopeless you're
only down seven games yes you do need to
win every game yes if you know you're
looking for the math on that one I'm
looking for the math one of the things
that our our algorithm does with the
stats we use a bunch of funny stuff that
we don't show but it actually calculates
based on how the match is going what the
predicted number of games is for each
time control so I wonder based on the
pace you guys have been playing whether
we could predict that pretty sure the
average number of bullet games is like
around like 8 or 9 I'm sure I'm sure
somebody one of our awesome staff
members helping is gonna remind me where
I'm wrong on that I think it's like 8 or
9 average full of games per half-hour
but maybe I'm coming ok what's going on
here really yeah yeah he's got it got a
little dicey for it's just so great
little Knight C for action you also lose
angel I thought you were gonna play
Queens accent nice d4 actually maybe not
I think you had Queen g6 and set a nice
c4 though John Queen g6 I yeah that
would have been good so am I still in
the game yeah is that what you're saying
I think so
the game don't hate the player hate the
game that's a really good move Jim why
are you so good what's the secret
um just lots of Starbucks coffee in
home-cooked Minnesota meals that wasn't
the answer I was looking for buddy
sometimes it's not the answer you want
to hear now John's good man John's one
of those guys who should be a GM it's
just uh making GM is tough
Thank You Danny making GM is tough that
is see even that move is good well that
one I did not much of a choice damn it I
don't even know what to do I chickened
out
I don't know what that is that's
horrible he kind of got horrible all of
a sudden my optimism has paid it yeah
really hasn't faded it really has peeps
here like quite quite seriously peaked
so where's the retire button we got it
the donation is coming back the Spartan
donut just donated $10 we're almost at
3750 we're gonna get there you guys are
doing great
where's the where's the retire but
there's a retire button you mean the
resign retire button that's his posh
posh Bernie got lost in time okay let's
go this is an hour now I think much of a
plate Magnus I mean for real so you're
saying I'm Magnus in this scenario no
I'm just saying imagine I played Magnus
oh I see you would be
I mean the score would be such an
abomination it would be disgraceful that
is true you know I think we could
probably put together a you versus
Magnus rook odds death match if you're
into that I think that that could be
something right there
losing the game a piece up was the one
that really nailed it you know nailed
the final nail in the coffin that had to
hurt that not only did it hurt I mean it
was just everything about it was just so
wrong you know it was just it was just
so wrong on so many different levels
being having a bottle of wine during the
broadcast also didn't help my cause I
know it always sounds like a good idea
it really does and you think you know
what if I just relaxed a little bit I'd
play better yeah but look at John he
hasn't moved in three and a half hours I
mean he's like he's like a rock over
there trying my best
let's do this hmm okay this is all a bit
rancid as per usual I mean to be honest
if I don't blunder it's acting here it's
kind of a miracle it's a miracle kind of
day you know holy smokes I'm hopeless
I've got a great pawn structure here I
thought this was good for me but you
know maybe it's just not good for me
sorry chess Bay making me laugh donating
for an area Hanson versus Bob van Campen
shirtless jello wrestling match so that
could be something
hmm this could be an interesting one
yeah it's over is it though or is it I
don't know who oh my gosh and the the
script is officially flipped
I didn't CD 45 I thought the kings were
just gonna come to the center but yeah
that's kind of yeah I guess a resign
story of your day that really is the
story of my day guys yeah nothing to be
done mmm yeah I guess you got a bit
lucky there whatever yeah
let's play Good Old Kings Indian attack
hi I was trying to show the climax of
that King and pawn ending for the fans I
wanted to bring the King in but then I
thought I found this idea and it wasn't
genius at all so yeah well guys it's
been a pleasure knowing you all Lords it
sounds like you're done with this match
by now I'm pretty done I'll be honest
video was just a bit too much to handle
you know mm-hmm we've all been in your
shoes all right that was too much just
as hard
we've not all been in my shoes like that
not like that that that one is just too
disgusting for words so you know I've
had a lot of good positions as well so
you know to lose in the fashion that I
have done is it's pretty disappointing
you know hmm whatever well you know yeah
well I was gonna say you know these
these deathmatches are difficult when
when things aren't clicking because it's
there's not a lot of opportunity to
recover so as much as it I mean this one
imma get it if I lose well this way your
your the spread in this match I mean
super grandmasters have lost by bigger
scores in this format and and I'm saying
that I know I'm dead serious not even to
you know not that I'm trying to make you
feel better I guess I am but it's true
right I mean the honest truth is that
when you're running and you have that
many games in a row and you don't have
time to kind of reflect it can be really
hard I mean do I think Wesley so is
really like 13 games worse than Magnus
Carlsen like not certainly not OTB but
in this kind of format you know one that
was when somebody gets rolling right I
mean Magnus is a monster and he makes it
makes children out of men so yeah for
sure
I mean it's hard so so in this
John Bartholomew was your Magnus yeah he
was my Magnus he is my Magnus forget
what we're getting a lot of
recommendations on good matches they
they want to do and it could be fun so I
mean we need out on the clock in this
one yeah whatever
ah oh I lost 67 points for that game
nice that's a lot of good it's a lot of
words okay one one kind of messes with
your head too it judge because she has a
bit strange you have to be really
careful how you evaluate positions when
your opponent is like under time
pressure yeah because they're not gonna
lose on time most likely and I feel like
I have all this time but it's really not
that much time right yeah no it works it
works both ways is this what you Baba
plays I mean the veresov well whatever
this system it's the varus off the the
flag and or the the gandalf the the
flute I do you pay I mean this is just
insane right I just won us off to six
moves in a personal yeah but you didn't
play it right I give consent in I mean
I'm not trying to defend a dubious
opening like I've been doing my whole
life but hey I'm here to defend the
dubious opening you play this opening
right Daniel yeah I've had some games in
this I really should have won that one
there were two games I think I should
have won that I didn't win that you know
you know that really cost me
so whatever the swings man the swings
are real brah yeah it's a matter of
momentum really is these death matches
really really is
like I just completely like didn't even
realize you were gonna go before there
go that's it that's what I was angling
for Lawrence cutting out apparently no
you still got I can still hear guys I
think I think we lost your connection
there Lawrence but we're all still here
I mean I'm here but but are you really
here I don't really I think you just
lost on time dude did you mean if like
what what I played my moves what I think
you I think you disconnected somehow we
lost you in the call and on sight
are you back online refresh before
immediately hmm let's redo that one just
play again or do you want to play it
from that position I mean it's kind of
ridiculous yeah yes I can restart the
game but somehow with somehow we lost
you
alright restart the game but add to the
time just in case I have a miracle all
right someone is accusing you're pulling
the plug many games ago believe me not
winning that one with the rook and three
pawns how the hell how much time did you
have in their game Lawrence I had loads
I don't know about loads but we had like
roughly the same amount of time this
this right here is exactly why we have a
clause that we don't like help out with
you know connection issues during like
speed chess cuz like if someone
disconnects or something and it gets too
tricky but okay right now Lawrence what
matters is you focusing on the now the
present I'm gonna move this philosophy
you right now I I need you to focus on
the present and win come back and win a
game here hold on a second I'm you did
crush me that last game
sometimes we play best when we have
nothing to lose you know and I mean
what's going at stake anymore
I mean seriously with your chess or
what's going on or I like with this game
because I thought you know you
disconnected that one I've been pretty
open about chests I comms issues that
one was on you buddy but it's okay we
want to redo that one we want to redo it
are you gonna set that up Danny yeah
yeah I'm trying to hold on a second I'm
just one man over here with one desire
take a breath
what's this
okay the game hold on a second the game
is Oh wrong colors well it shows me as
being white lol Oh Bob will abort it
okay we're gonna redo it and then I'm
gonna set up a time okay we're saving it
for one one again yeah yeah and I'm
gonna set up three guys it's time okay
so that you have this that you actually
have the right amount of time okay here
we go now I think we're good
yeah you can start making moves I'll be
adjusting your time as you go wow I can
do those kind of things they're magical
now you both have 35 seconds it's like a
you know it's like a wizard kind of
thing it's a weird for sure fo sho okay
I don't know I'm playing some rat I'm
playing some random moves here folks I
think there should be three might have
given me some problems there Bishop III
was really much more sensible forced me
to play e5 and much better Knight f5
roles anyway this is this is going great
this is really horrendous stuff it's
going great this is horrendous this is
really horrendous stuff people want to
come back they want you to win the next
few games out of pure pride to get your
donations to or thousands so right now
see it Lawrence it's time for you to
take a breath and get those wins so we
can get those donations up come on
everybody we only have 13 minutes left
it's not like I don't want it guys you
know they're all saying that I don't
want it I really want it there we go 391
that's a that's a number that's a number
that's a number
mm-hmm Queen in could never be bad
especially in a bullet game right more
donations coming in a hundred dollars
from Lawrence Trent's ego was just
donated oh man that's great whoever came
up with that name and had the had the
wherewithal to donate a hundred dollars
you are a class I mean come on Lawrence
that would that might that might be the
icing on the cake right there we go well
12 minutes Lawrence Trent's ego just
donated $100 and apparently left its
dignity back in the five-minute portion
but Thank You Lawrence Trancy go we got
to get Lawrence Trent's checkmark I want
to see a donation from them Lawrence
Lawrence checkmark if we could get to
4,000 let's get some full thousand guys
come on we're at 38 40 now that's
impressive
they're saying you don't have the purest
motivations by calling for that donation
John you're like yeah I want another
seventy-five dollars in my pocket let's
get another hundred we put on the board
right
can I get 4k 4k who who is this guy I
don't think that's a very good move by
me I mean who the hell is this guy he's
supposed to be some random I am from
Minnesota or something yeah that's
literally who he is a random I am from
Minnesota but he's really good he is
really good it kind of makes me sick
like he's probably even gonna beat me
here which makes me even lost it hmm I
wish it would have just been a bit
closer going into the one minute you
know so it wasn't like a foregone
conclusion yeah you don't want to
wipeout I mean it was kind of sad how it
all transpired what is this Minnesota
South Dakota really he's just gonna do
now oh my oh god we got to go all in
baby oh my god no I just saw that his
openings been working well I mean I
should have stuck with this thang
I mean for god sake this is like not so
clear though is it I don't know I don't
know I mean King h8 I'm not sure about
that was questionable okay the price I'm
gonna do something here I'm gonna call
it down here and I'm gonna say well done
job on your resigning you're throwing in
the towel hey we want to get you
colleges hey Laurence your ego just
showed up okay it wants its chess game
back alright make five good chess moves
for the love of all that is holy okay
things are degenerating here things are
getting worse I mean
things are getting worse that is this is
a better position than you had last game
though that's true so you can take some
solace in there right sorry I looked
away to chat for like five seconds and
you guys have pushed every bone on the
board so yeah I mean we're getting into
the Freestyle section of the match Danny
yeah have you known about freestyle
chess close to freestyle rap didn't we
already say that that's what you know me
or nevermind
down with OPP yeah that's right I can't
even pretend to be cool what is wrong
with me okay this is a setup rather
embarrassingly trap bishop or can you
Castle you candy castle yes yeah you're
almost just nine six finish yes yeah
the king in the Rope they change places
Lawrence rents IM title just donated a
dollar that's good at least if nothing
else these are all quit these are all
these are all clippable don't quit
Lawrence just donated a dollar everybody
and their cousin is about to make a
troll named for you Lawrence and but at
least they're putting money where
they're troll troll name is so you're
welcome
they're trolling you yeah okay Lawrence
you have a chance to win the training
games oh is that he's got a big chin you
have a chance to win this game I'm
trying to get you to wake up he's got a
very big chance for this one my play
like backfired a little bit you know
okay get my nights at five well yeah
donate a dollar when you say chance to
win this way you really mean is no gonna
win this right hey hey now young man I'm
gonna put you in your room with that
attitude
yeah you have everybody on the edge of
your their seat about whether you're
gonna win another game so come on to be
fair it's not like I played atrociously
I have played atrociously but that's not
really been the story this whole match
right somehow
it is not what has the story been then I
don't I mean can you give me a game here
I mean for real he's got an active King
dominating like light squares figuring
out if you have a knight in bullet you
can't resign that's actually that's like
that's like religious online chess stuff
right there that's dogma I just take it
Wow can't resign oh there you go he did
it you a knight you might regret that
decision
Lawrence transfer tyre meant fund just
donated a dog okay Lawrence it's okay
guys there was a stalemate chance there
for a second yeah thank God for the
seafoam buddy John you got your wish you
got your wish Lawrence Trent's Lawrence
friends check mark just donated a dollar
oh thank you close to four K hey and
right now we're inching our way toward
3900 with these dollar donations so I
think I think what they want there is
another win by you if you make it three
in a row you just want to game Lawrence
for the first time in an hour and a half
that's right the check mark has spoken
I missed a I missed a donation there
from Wally tahleen Khan who donated
August for Danny for pronouncing my name
correctly more if you and John recognize
who it is who is I mean I'm drawing a
blank
who was the donation oh my god oh man as
corny as it is and as much criticism as
I take for it sometimes ouch town is the
only way to describe something this is
the most disgusting loves lawrence trent
suffering just donated $1 in nine cents
okay we have less than five minutes
seriously everybody this has been a
wonderful show whether we reach for Kate
or not you guys have really been the
highlight here meeting all of you in
chat not the chest do you guys have been
the highlight of the show the donations
the support the proof that chess is here
to stay on Twitch and there is some
amore ins Lawrence's wine bottle just
donated a dollar 21 sorry I had to stop
my rant to give a shout out to a great a
great name yeah thank you to everyone
who's donated yeah and thanks for
everybody remember I'm gonna be matching
some of that for charity which is great
yep so we'll get that sorted out and
kudos to you for agreeing to that
Lawrence you didn't have to but that's
great no I mean look I am wait well I
had some really bad news recently about
a friend so you know anything I can do
to help like any any decent cause I'm
really cool to do that so you know I
mean we can discuss which charity I'd
like it to be a cancer charity as
possible yeah if that's all right with
you
yeah we can definitely do that while
lead selling kaunas is a fan on twitter
who's who's communicated with us before
that's that's who he is so John we also
received another $10 donation there
Lawrence so that you can buy another
bottle of wine after this no but
seriously I mean it's amazing honestly
super lucky to have the opportunity
bring people together support the chest
community and send donations to charity
to go with it are pretty awesome but hey
Carlo feels bad for Trent just donated a
dollar sometimes you just got to take it
was the statement that came with it
so that's when nothing works nothing
works right
guys like when nothing works at all
sometimes it just doesn't work so you
just got a you know just got to go with
it yeah like his pieces are really doing
numbers on me here
they're all coming in they're all coming
in look at that look at that saving
defensive move Lawrence is the other
night that would have been a little bit
better at this point John is
subconsciously rooting for you or he
would have known I didn't even see that
he could do that at the end gee this is
just the most horrific show of chess
episode this is quite the logjam on the
kingside lot I mean a lot of people
asking if they can get a piece of the
action of Lawrence while he's on tilt
like this on chess calm afterwards but
retire for real soon yeah it's retiring
you know thanks to the chess TV chat all
our premium members their shout-out to
Donna shout out to all our diamond
members title players all the subs of
the twitch TV slash channel we got
follow lawrence on twitter we got one
more this is it okay guys I'm making an
executive decision whoever wins this
game wins the whole match right here in
the main you see when you're a little
kid okay how about just next point wins
how about just next point wins right now
okay in the meantime see jgp just donate
$100 and we're almost at 4,000 thank you
so much I'm CJ I'm a poor kid but I love
these matches on chess calm my favorite
chef side mind blowing that is some
amazing support that's cool and wait we
just got cheesy Leicester just donate
$100 we have smashed through the $4,000
barrier rabo guys ID or drunk then I
didn't even see Queen sex p7 so this is
amazing
I love the twitch chat love the chess
community this is amazing I'm so
thankful for the support here Lorenson
and John awesome stuff yeah thank you to
everyone and I want to say that this is
not the end by any means on Twitch this
is just the beginning because you know
Danny and I have talked we've got some
big stuff planned Lawrence I know you're
on Twitch yeah in fact that was part of
my preparation watching you entitled
Tuesday oh wow okay that didn't go
particularly well um no it did you
scored like six and a half out of nine
didn't you I can't remember
you did well thank you for the last
final donation Hakkar oh the savage done
it I've been missing others but you guys
are all just absolutely amazing Lawrence
and and John this may be the coolest one
of the coolest chess events we've ever
done here I mean this is that's amazing
the support and again all of this love
going directly to these two guys and our
charities so thank you to everybody who
supported with donations today yeah
thank you guys so much been a pleasure
fans excited about John getting on
twitch Lawrence's channel every year we
love at four thousand eighty three
dollars and 21 cents Dave get out of it
what would you have predicted prior to
this match the amount that would be
donated uh didn't we talk about affair I
was I mean okay this this is I don't
want this to sound bad at all I just had
no idea that there was so much love and
amazing support I was hoping we could
get another thousand you know I I
thought it would be really cool given
that we had you know I had two thousand
on the line from chest I come to start I
was hoping to get a thousand but we got
we crashed through double that two
thousand plus just amazing they're still
coming in and just been awesome yeah
anyway I want to say big thanks to
everybody yeah who followed you watch
them
who supported all of you guys crawling
we actually love you I love you thanks
to John as well you know much better
player certainly on the day didn't take
my chances when I needed to in order for
it to be even a competitive match John
deserved big winner and you know looking
forward to donating to the charity Judd
Gregg Shahar da to go about you buddy
will sort that out ASAP yeah Greg you're
welcome by the way sorry I was talking
to Greg Greg you're welcome Greg you're
welcome
and yeah remember to follow me and John
there are a lot a lot a lot of stuff
lined up for Chester come with you no
screaming various other words were the
protest League coming up right away
during our that's right week already I'm
gonna be streaming with the one and only
jinsha Hardy legend so really looking
forward to that and we're gonna be
growing our channels respectively and
everybody else the chess brass everybody
else it's gonna just be a powerhouse
chance Oh excited for the protest I
guess you can be cool yeah I'll be I'll
be doing commentary regularly will be
watching fins in fact I think I have
your division John I think okay me and
the teams for the pro Chesley commentary
this year we have Lawrence and Jen
Shahadah
we have Simon Williamson Anna Rudolph we
have Danny wrench and Robert Hess and
then we cap it off with David prowess
and Ben Feingold at the West Coast
division so we have some awesome
commentary duo's I think lined up I
think it's gonna be a blast emic blasts
Orson John and predictions for the
Minnesota Blizzard as they compete the
protest like how you guys gonna do this
year uh well you always want to have big
expectations but I'm really excited
about our team especially since our top
player Andrew tank just made his grand
master title and within our state here
in Minnesota we have a lot of great
talent yeah also we recruited some
players abroad as well so that's
supplementing our the free masters and I
will be playing probably about half the
matches and I'm also thinking about
doing some commentary at my own on my
twitch channel once I got that great
idea so if I'm not playing I'm probably
gonna try to do that if I'm in town
awesome
well you know what seriously guys
Laurens all seriousness all jokes aside
I know it wasn't your best day today
John and I both know that your your
obviously your your chest scan and is
often better tough day but hey these
things can be a landslide so I I'm
sometimes not surprised when even the
match together John asked me what I
predicted coming in I honestly would
have had to match at about plus two or
three for John if you asked me and that
was kind of what RTL go said right
that's about that's about what I would
have thought but but John you impressed
you were awesome and we know we know I
know personally how tough it can be to
play against you Lawrence what can you
say about him he's just like an
emotional Rock what I know about John is
he just very rarely beats himself the
thing that makes no ovens have said that
to really good me is that the thing that
surprised me about John is the positions
where he's playing on dead lost and like
the one where he was a piece down and
then one of the very first blitz ones
where I had this rook in three and I
allowed his get in and not if you don't
win those who just got zero chance in an
inning even remotely close match had I
won those two got like 2-3 with the one
minutes ago
who knows what what could have happened
but or of course when i'm -7 with we're
just the one minute left i've got no
chance the momentum matters a lot of
music often comes down to yeah pivotal
games as far as the momentum goes and
it's hard yeah no but I mean I really
enjoyed I want to thank just calm as
well for for hosting this yes
thank I mean I really mean it thank you
everybody yeah this is really cool I
mean I think about this sort of thing in
terms of I know you guys have had death
matches before but streaming on Twitch
seeing the support that we guys have
that we have in the chat the donations
this is pioneering stuff in my opinion
there's a lot of fun I've been naughty
time for chess I think I think it'll be
cool who knows how many donations we
could get if we got Magnus in one of
these two anyway I'm just me no but
seriously guys John congratulations to
you I meant what I said you are somebody
who's super hard to because you don't
beat yourself all of us are rooting for
you to be that next the next GM here
Lawrence yeah thank you guys to blow up
your channel on Twitch and we know
John's gonna be right after you on
Twitch here so thank you both shout out
to chess Bay
uh all the big all the big donors all
the little donors every every single
donor sorry if I'm forgetting some of
the names Ben Ben Ben a few for ours but
seriously Ches Bay all the all the love
and support you guys don't bring thank
you so much haters everyone who tuned in
and thank you Lawrence for being such a
good sport and Danny for putting up with
this for four hours don't go anywhere
because as soon as I say bye we are
going to be hosting Grand Master Robert
Hess with John ercel they are in a knee
deep in some analysis of end games so I
see the viewers dropping a little bit
but don't go anywhere stick around to
support John Herschel and Robert has go
ahead and subscribe to John urschel's
channel and Robert Hess might also be
somebody who you see getting more
involved bringing some chest love to the
twitch community so everybody Robert
Lawrence Rock not Robert John Lawrence
everybody peace out love happiness and
all that stuff see you soon bye guys
everybody